- I fell asleep in the bath once
with a nose bleed and it
was scary waking up to that.
You ever fell asleep in a bath?
- No, that's how people die.
- No, it was like a shallow bath.
- You could still die.
- How am I gonna like...
(guys laughing)
- Hello and welcome to
the Trash Taste Podcast.
This is now episode two.
Hopefully, unless some-
- Unless we fucked up somehow.
(guys laughing)
I am your host for the day, Gigguk.
And joining me is Connor from C, oh.
(guys laughing)
- Connor from CDawg.
- Connor from Connor Dawg VA.
And Joey from The Anime Man.
- Hi.
(laughing)
- Wow, that was a lot more
energetic than last time.
- I know, right?
- Yeah, I just like came in
nonchalantly like I guess
welcome to the podcast.
- Hey guys.
Welcome to Trash Taste Podcast.
I should be like that 'cause
I'm gonna say right now,
apologies if I'm a bit out of
it, I'm slightly hung over,
'cause it was my birthday
celebrations yesterday.
- Woo!
- How old are you? 47?
I am, well, in YouTube years,
yes, because I've been around
since the beginning of YouTube basically,
but no, I've finally
hit my dirty thirties.
- Oh my God.
That's scary, dude.
- I know.
- I always forget the huge
age gap between us three.
- Yeah.
- Because between Connor
and Garnt, there's what?
- Seven.
- Seven years?
- Seven years.
- I'm 23, yeah.
- That's fucking insane.
I forget all the time that you are 23.
- Everyone thinks I'm like
30, especially in Japan.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's the beard.
- Yeah, everyone is just beard,
you immediately have like four mortgages,
a car and two kids.
(guys laughing)
- But because it is or
it was Garnt's birthday,
I got him a gift.
- I wonder what this could be.
- I wonder.
- It's manga.
(laughing)
- See, we've just reached that age
where this just a acceptable
gift that you can give anyone.
- Yeah.
- So let's do the unboxing,
shall we?
- ASMR unboxing.
- ASMR unboxing time.
- Yeah.
And you see we've already got wine glasses
'cause we had no idea what
this could possibly be.
But ooh.
Ooh, ooh fancy.
- Ooh, okay.
- Yeah, it is fancy.
So basically at our supermarket,
I'll tell a story while
you're opening that.
So basically at the supermarket
that we all live near
which I'm not gonna say,
there's like a booze section,
like a liquor store section.
And I didn't know for the longest time
that not only is there
a liquor store section
but there's like a
dedicated section to wine.
- Okay.
- Like a wine room, I guess.
So I got an Italian one I think.
- Barolo.
- I misread this, at
first I was like Boruto?
(guys laughing)
I was like, is this the anime one?
- Boruto wine.
- It just sounds like a
generic "Dragon Ball" villain.
- Yeah.
- Barolo.
- Goku Barolo.
- Thank you very much, Joey.
- Yeah, no worries.
- I don't know too much about wines
apart from if they're in-
- Red or white.
(guys laughing)
- Yeah, what color is it?
- If they're red or white
or if they're one of the 10
from "Drops of God."
(guys laughing)
- I don't think it's
that but Barolo is like,
I think it's like pretty
well known in Italy, I think?
The guy was like, "Oh yeah,
if you want like a well known
Italian wine, get Barolo."
So hey, if anyone's watching this episode
or listening to this
episode and you're Italian
let us know if you know Barolo.
- I just think they're gonna
be like the fuck is a Barolo?
(guys laughing)
We don't drink Barolo.
- That's what they call Boruto in Italy.
(guys laughing)
- I just think it's funny
because how I got into wine,
because how I got into wine initially
was literally "Drops of God."
Because before that I was like
why does anyone drink wine?
I just want a cold beer.
I don't want to like,
but you read "Drops of God" once
and you're like, I love wine!
Wine's great!
- I read "Drops of God" on a flight.
I think it was, when was the flight?
I don't know it was from
like America or somewhere.
And I remembered reading "Drops of God"
and you know when like
the little cart comes by?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they're like, "What
do you want to drink?"
And I was like of course I want wine.
I'm a connoisseur of fine tastes.
Of course, why even ask me the question?
- Yeah, I was about to ask,
I hope you were drinking
wine on the flight
while you were reading it.
- So she gets out the
little bottle of wine,
they crack open, and pours it
into this plastic cup for me.
And it was like the most
pathetic drink I'd ever had
because I was sitting there
like swirling this plastic cup
that like a 10 year old
would drink a drink out of.
Just being like, "Yeah, that's good."
- Yeah, because table wine,
we all know table wine
on flights is basically
just like grape juice
with hand sanitizer in
it, like it's disgusting.
- I mean, 'cause you, you can't even taste
like things that aren't like
super salty on flights anyways.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I feel like wine is the worst thing.
- I feel like it's that
point when you're watching
something that's super good.
Like for example, when
you're watching "Shokugeki"-
- And you just wanna cook.
- You're like this food looks amazing
and you're sitting there
with your fucking takeaway convenient meal
and you're like "Mm, this
is this is kind of like
A5 beef that I'm eating now."
(guys laughing)
- It's A5 beef if I just
imagine hard enough.
- There's nothing more orgasmic
than Kraft Mac and cheese.
(guys laughing)
- Wow, thank you, wow.
- Oh yeah, let's pour that.
Ooh.
- It's quite light.
- From such a height!
- From such a height.
(guys laughing)
- Which was another meme that originated
from "Drops of God."
(guys laughing)
- Oh, come on.
- I'm sorry, okay?
- Absolute amateur hour.
- Oh my God.
- I love how you're like tilting that.
- I'm sorry, okay?
I'm sorry!
(guys laughing)
I'm not a waiter.
- When is the podcast
actually gonna start?
- The podcast is starting now.
Happy birthday.
- Cheers.
- Happy birthday, Garnt.
- Thank you very much.
- Congratulations.
- So boys, what are we discussing today?
What are the topics on mind?
- I mean, on the topic of, you know,
we talked about, 'cause we live
quite close together, right?
We live within walking distance.
- A five minute walking distance.
- Yeah, so I guess I think
a good topic would be
what our experiences are
like living here in Japan
now that we've all finally moved here.
'Cause we just moved here,
how many months have we
been living here now?
- It's actually like eight.
- Eight months.
- Which is crazy 'cause-
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
October so it's just hit June.
So it was like, and this
was like middle of June.
It was like seven and
a half months I guess.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Right.
- But yeah.
- That's scary.
It does not feel like it at all.
- No, no.
- Well, to be fair,
the last two months I might as well
have been living in fucking Australia.
(guys laughing)
Quarantine does things to you.
I hadn't heard anyone speak Japanese
for like about two months
except for like that brief moment
when you'd go out to buy groceries,
and I just forget that
I was living in Japan.
- Yeah. Legit.
I remember catching the train
for the first time in like two months.
And I was just like,
the world is full of wonder!
(guys laughing)
- I felt like I was, like "Cast Away."
Like when he like came back-
- Tom Hanks.
- Tom Hanks after "Cast Away"
when he came back to humanity.
He's like (gasping).
(guys laughing)
Wilson, you know?
- I don't know if you guys have yet
but I still haven't gone into Tokyo yet.
- Oh.
- I went there for-
- Like central Tokyo.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think the first time I
went there was like yesterday
and that was literally
just 'cause it was like
quarantine was over just on
like the day of my birthday.
- Yeah.
- So I'm like woo, this is fate.
I'm gonna go out and have some nice food.
But even now, there's like a
lot of places are still closed
so it's still not like
everything's open yet,
but yeah, it's been a
really fast eight months.
It hasn't felt like eight months at all.
I guess my first question to you guys-
(glass dings)
My first question to you guys is like
what made you decide to move
to Japan in the first place?
'Cause you've been here
for how many years now?
- I've been here four years now.
- Yeah. I guess for you,
it's more obvious though.
- I mean, yeah, 'cause I've spent what?
Like half my life here
and I have family up north and in Tokyo.
At least with me like,
I'm pretty sure I've said
this in videos before,
but like I was gonna move to Japan
after I graduated from uni anyway,
because I think this
was like back when I had
maybe like 20K, 30K subs.
So I wasn't doing it full-time at all.
- Yeah.
- I was in my second year of university
and I was interning at
like a Japanese IT company,
which I believe is now defunct.
Like it doesn't exist
anymore I don't think,
so glad that internship
never went through.
- Yeah.
- But yeah,
so I was gonna move to Japan anyway,
because like it just makes sense for me
because I'm fluent in
both English and Japanese,
which is such a huge plus here.
Like if you know both languages,
you can pretty much get a job anywhere.
- We'll get to that. We'll get to that.
- And like no one in
Australia gives a shit
if you can speak Japanese.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like my dad works
at like a Japanese IT
company for 30 years.
He can't speak a word of Japanese.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's because no one in the
office can speak Japanese,
but here it's like if
you can speak English,
you can do business with
anybody in or out of Japan.
So it just was like a natural
process for me to like,
okay, I get my paper,
I work at some fucking IT company in Japan
and then we're all good.
- Yeah, it's funny
because I reckon one of the few industries
where Japanese can be
super, super important
is anime and manga, right?
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Yeah.
- You maxed out your luck there.
- Yeah, exactly.
So either way, It was
just a natural path for me
to move here.
But instead of doing that desk job
that I had set my plans on,
YouTube, for me, blew up
like in my third year of uni
when I graduated.
So I was just like, all right, I'll-
- Guess I'll do this.
- Guess I'll do YouTube
for as long as I can
and then-
- You're still doing it.
- I'm still doing it,
somehow I'm still doing it.
I know, it's crazy.
The story of or I guess
like the original plan
that was brought up to
you guys about moving here
was like a year ago?
- Yeah, 'cause I wanted
to move here for a while.
I remember since we first met each other
and since my first trip to Japan,
I was like I could really
see myself living here.
And this is not like the
typical weeb kind of fantasy.
(guys laughing)
I actually never had that.
I remember back in the day
when it was like mid 2000s,
the weeb dream was to live in Japan and-
- Work in the anime industry.
It was just like a fucking dream
that nobody had ever proven or, you know?
So it was just that weeb dream,
but I never really wanted that.
I was like I'm happy with a normal career.
I'd never really fantasized
about going to Japan.
But I remember the first time I came here,
it was so eye-opening for
me because it was like
you know that feeling
when you're like, man,
this country just works in a lot of ways
and it's do with my job
so I'm like this could be
a really good opportunity for me.
- Yeah, I definitely felt the same thing
with how I thought about Japan.
I couldn't have cared
less about living here.
And I thought people who
were learning the language,
at the time I was like 15, 14,
I was like, that's kind of cringe, bro.
(guys laughing)
But like now, that I've
actually started to learn it-
- God, I regret it so much.
- I regret that I didn't learn any
because I could have been like
a few months ahead at least
of learning the language.
- I wish I was more weeaboo.
Like now that the cringey
weeaboo phase is over.
I wish I was that cringey weeaboo
because that would give me so much more
of an advantage now
that I'm her ein Japan.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And a part of me,
I remember when I used to think that way,
like anyone who's learning
it, is was just like wow.
It's so sad, you're never
actually gonna learn it.
But to be fair if you're
learning anything,
any other kinds of language,
especially if you only speak one,
I think that's like good on
you, better yourself, you know?
Like who gives a shit?
And I really regret that
I thought that everyone
who's learning Japanese
because of anime's pathetic.
But then again, I was like
an edgy teenager, right?
And we all think that
and yeah, like you said,
I had no intention or want to live here.
I was pretty content in the UK.
And even when I visited
here, I thought, wow,
this is an amazing place
to come visit, right?
But I don't think I was
still sold yet on moving here
because I think, I don't
know about you guys,
but I really need friends.
(guys laughing)
- I need that social interaction.
- I'm not speaking for every weeb,
but I do need to have
friends that I see often,
otherwise I really get like upset.
- You're like the
antithesis of every weeaboo.
- Yeah, I need to socialize
or it really starts to take a toll on me.
I was just like, I really like worried
that I wouldn't be able to
have a good social circle
and meet people
- Yeah.
- I mean, luckily that
hasn't been the case, but-
- 'Cause I guess the big
difference between you and me is
that I've already like, before Japan,
I had already lived in Thailand
for a good like three years.
So I had experience moving
to a different country
and finding new friends and
to me it was like, okay,
I'm just starting the
process all over again.
Then it's just a new adventure, I guess.
So it was a lot easier for me to decide,
hey, I'm gonna move to Japan.
I guess the biggest thing
that made me think is that,
do I really want to go
through this process again?
How long do I see myself
actually living here?
And to me it was like,
this is the last big move
I'm gonna do before I kind
of start to think about-
- Yeah, that's crazy.
- Staying in one place
instead of flying to different
countries every few months,
which is what I was doing before.
- I don't know how you
were doing that for like-
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you were going
from Thailand's a UK to America and then-
- Full triangle.
- I had three offices.
I had one in Thailand, one
in the UK and one in America.
- That's major entrepreneur
moves right there, dude.
I have three offices all over the world.
- Look how many corner
offices this man has.
- The traveling just gets to you, man.
- [Connor] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- You know when you're at university,
you're like I just want to travel,
I want to get out, I want
to experience new things,
but you do it every year
for about a good four years
and it fucking gets to you.
- Yeah.
I think I'm definitely
starting to phase out of that
like just any excuse to travel is great,
'cause now I'm really starting
to detest some travel.
- Remember when traveling
to AnimeCons was exciting
and now the thought of
having to go on a plane
to get somewhere,
to me, it's a lot harder
than it used to be.
- I guess, because it was just,
of because how it's become,
it's always a 10 plus hour flight
and that's like the thing
that is really draining.
We must sound, God, I'm so annoyed
we have to travel so much.
(laughing)
- I hate it when these
cons pay for our travel.
Ugh!
- Right.
I mean, I guess it happens
when you travel a shit ton.
I'm sure anyone who has
like parents or family,
friends who work, their
whole business has to travel,
it does become draining pretty quickly.
- Because it is a job
at the end of the day.
People want to travel, but if
you've ever had a office job,
which I did for the BBC and
you had to travel to Europe,
you have to travel to these places
and it's just hours and hours
of traveling for the job.
It drains you no matter
where you're traveling to,
if you travel there enough,
it'll eventually drain you.
- There's a massive difference
between traveling for pleasure
and traveling for business.
I mean, it might not seem
there's a huge difference,
especially to someone
who doesn't travel a lot.
But after a while,
you're just like, oh man,
I have to go on this flight.
Versus yay, I get to go on this flight.
- I think the only time
I'm excited for a flight
is when Netflix drops a whole show
that I'm like super hyped for.
It's like, sweet, I got 10 hours
of no one bothering me.
- Yeah.
- I can watch this, hell yeah.
That's like the only time.
But the worst is when you get to the app
and you're like fuck, I
didn't download anything.
- Oh God.
- And you're like oh no.
I have to pay for shitty wifi
to scroll on Twitter for 12 hours.
- Cool. I have to play this
solitaire game for 10 hours
that doesn't require any internet.
- It's like when you sit down for a shit
and you realize your phone's on 1% battery
and you're like what do I do
when this battery runs out?
- So.
- Oh, go on.
- Another thing is time differences
and adjusting sleep schedule.
I got a question for you
because we went through
the same kind of flights.
How did you find the traveling
to the Crunchyroll Anime Awards?
Because to put things in perspective,
we were there for like one day, two days.
And we had to travel, how
long did you have to travel?
- 16 ish hours I think it was
for the Crunchyroll Anime
Awards, yeah, it was around that.
- For me it was 21 hours of traveling.
- Yeah, because you were
in the UK at the time.
- No, no, I was in Thailand
which is even worse.
- Yeah.
- Jesus.
- That was the straw that
broke the camel's back.
After that, I was like,
if I'm traveling too far,
there's gotta be something, man.
- Yeah, I remember hanging out with you
after you came back from that
and you were still pissed off about
that you had to endure that.
And I'm like, all right, well.
- I just want to say cheers Crunchyroll
for not inviting me to that.
You saved me a lot of trouble.
- It's a great experience.
I'm trying to be brand friendly here.
(guys laughing)
- Thank you brand.
- I'm not saying the experience is bad.
The thing that was bad was me
having to adjust immediately
to like a 16 hour time difference
and then two days later
have to adjust back
and try to be in a working state.
- Not to mention, in between
that you have to go on stage
in front of thousands of
people and be like, yeah, yeah,
just nail this, don't
act like you're sleepy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No pressure.
- It was fun overall though.
I liked networking with people
and meeting other YouTubers
you don't get to see often
is pretty fun.
But anyway, cycling
back to the Japan stuff.
When in your timeline, did you get
I guess presented with the
idea or the offer of moving?
Like when was that?
Do you remember the date-ish?
- I can't remember the dates.
- The exact time and
location, like roughly.
- When was it for you
because if you remember-
- I know that you knew,
the offered had presented
itself to you before me.
And I think it must have been
in either like February, March-ish.
It was like three or months
before AX I know that.
- Yeah, I remember it was
like at least a year ago
when I heard about it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so it was, I think,
I guess from the timeline
where it came up to me
knowing it was a possibility
to me actually like finishing the move
is probably like what?
Seven, eight months.
- Oh yeah.
It's been well over a year for me.
- Yeah, 'cause I knew
that you knew before me.
- So yeah, how it happened for me was
I remember I was just sitting
in a BookWalker meeting
and we were just talking about,
I can't remember, some random stuff
about what BookWalker
wants to do in the future.
And then the person who I
was talking to, which is,
can I mention your name Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] I guess.
Don't throw me under the bus.
- I'm not gonna throw you under the bus.
- I will.
(guys laughing)
- So Meilyne, who is
basically our manager,
one of our managers now,
she basically just asked me,
"Have you ever thought
about moving to Japan?"
And that was just kind of a,
it just kind of came
out of nowhere for me.
I didn't know how to react to that.
I was like that's a loaded question,
but I mean, I'm not gonna say no,
but you know when you're
like asked a question-
- And it's obviously for a purpose,
like it's not a hypothetical.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you're like, oh, this
could actually be a thing.
And so I went away, I thought about it
and I was like, yeah,
if I'm not gonna do it
now than when in my life
am I gonna do it?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And then I guess the
idea just grew from there
from it being a hypothetical question
to what needs to happen to
be able to bring an anituber
to Japan as a job?
- Yeah.
- Right. Right.
- And so that started my whole process.
When did you hear about it?
- Yeah, I think it was,
It must've been around March or February.
I'm not a 100% sure.
I think I was on call with Meilyne
and I think Meilyne brought it up to me
and it was basically the same thing.
Where it was like the hypothetical-
- Do you like Japan?
(guys laughing)
- Yeah, something like that, right?
And I think I was just like "Oh wait,"
well maybe I was in Japan at the time.
It was something, right?
The thing where it was like not concrete
And it was like, hey,
think about it, you know?
Like do you want to do it?
And then I think two or three months later
it became a bit more serious of like,
okay, do you want to do it?
I think, was that similar thing to you?
- Yeah, exactly.
- I think we had time to think about it
and then seriously they asked us.
- Yeah and it went from a hypothetical to,
oh, oh, this is actually happening.
I'm moving to Japan and this-
- 'Cause yeah, I don't
think I've spoke to you
about your thoughts on it.
Maybe I might have at the
time, but I can't remember.
But were you like from the
first time you got heard
or you were given the offer,
were you gonna take it or?
- Yeah, I think I was always
going to take it I think
because I had wanted to
move to Japan for a while
even if it was for a little bit,
hadn't really put much
thought into how long
I wanted to stay here but I was thinking,
you only get this chance
once in your life.
If I hated it, then like great,
at least at least I've done it, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But I was pretty concrete
when I got the offer
that I was gonna take it.
What I was more worried about was how
it was actually going to happen
or what the process is-
- Yeah, I think there's
a lot of stuff like that,
where I guess 'cause we'd only interacted
with BookWalker through Meilyne,
I think maybe we were a bit like skeptical
about what goes on in the back end, right?
We were like I don't know
what's happening, right?
- Yeah.
- But they're great
by the way, they took
care of us very nicely.
And Meilyne will kill
me if I say otherwise.
(guys laughing)
- It's against the contract
to say anything negative.
But I think the huge
advantage for at least you two
was the fact that and
I know a lot of people
who don't do this and definitely should
is that you guys visited
Japan enough times to-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, twice.
(laughing)
- Well, I mean, you know.
- I was there for a while-
- Yeah but I know a lot of stories
of like people who move here
just thinking like, oh,
Japan is this wonderful place
and you know, like nothing could go wrong
and everyone's so friendly.
And then they move here
and their expectations are
just completely rejected.
- Yeah. There's a lot of
stuff that's different
between visiting and moving here,
which we can get into later.
- Yeah, because for me,
I think it goes back to the mentality of
I never felt like moving here
or I never thought I
would want to move here
because of the fact that I liked anime.
I think that's the biggest thing.
If you want to move to
Japan just purely for anime,
you're gonna have a bad time.
- Throw away the weeaboo dreams, guys.
It's not real.
- There's pretty worse reasons,
but it's pretty one of the worser ones.
- Yeah, like for me, in terms
of my exposure to anime,
it hasn't actually increased too much
compared to when I was living in Thailand
because there is like a massive
anime fandom in Thailand
and just Asia in general.
There's a big difference
between say England to Japan,
but from Thailand to Japan.
I still have to watch anime online
because you can't watch on TV
'cause I don't understand it yet.
- Yeah and even If you did,
the schedule of airing is so weird.
- Yeah, I'm not gonna stay up till 3:00 am
to watch-
- It's so sporadic.
- It's just not worth it.
- Exactly.
- It kind of like reminds me of
like old cartoon
broadcast schedule, right?
Like it's all over the place
and repeats constantly.
Like it's weird.
Yeah, anyway, I think when I
was presented with the offer
I didn't initially want,
I wasn't that keen on it
mainly because I didn't
really know anything.
And when someone's like, "Hey,
do you want to come here to this country?"
And it's like, okay, I mean, Japan's cool,
but I don't-
- It's a big decision.
- Yeah, I literally don't know anything.
I think over time, I just,
especially when I found out
that you were gonna go 100%,
I think that was like, all right,
well at least I have my boys here.
So if I do get lonely, we good.
But I mean, yeah, meeting
friends wasn't a problem anyway
but I think-
- It is scary though.
- It is.
I think I'll go into later with like
what I think is important
when you move here
and then just got to the point
where I had nothing better going on
and then people gave me so much shit
for saying that on my video, by the way.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, I literally said in my video,
I said, "I just had
nothing better going on,
that's why I moved here."
And people think that
I'm being like nonchalant
or joking, like I didn't.
When you're a YouTuber you
don't have anything to do
other than YouTube and
hang out with your friends
and do whatever you
need to do to be happy.
But I literally had
nothing better going on,
so I'm in my head
there's no reason why I wouldn't take this
'cause it gives me a purpose
to just better myself
as a person, I get to learn new things,
get to meet new people.
- I mean, that's a huge
reason why I moved as well as
is because like in Australia like-
- What are you doing?
- Right.
(guys laughing)
I had like great friends
from uni and high school
who I would hang out with
every now and then, right?
And I had places to go to
but it wasn't exciting anymore for me,
it was just routine.
- Yeah, that's how it is.
- And I hate getting into
routine with anything, right?
So I was like, yeah, I mean, you know?
I haven't like, yes I've spent
half my life here technically
but I haven't really like gone out
to fully explore the country
and even four years later,
I'm nowhere near close
to exploring this place.
There are so many more
places I want to go to.
- I still haven't left Tokyo.
It's been like eight months
and I haven't left Tokyo.
- That road trip that
we planned is happening.
All right? Once the rona
is gone, it's happening.
- I've left Tokyo once.
(guys laughing)
The decision to move
to Japan funnily enough
was probably the easiest
part of the process.
- Really?
- Oh, yeah.
Okay, well, first of all,
I mean, you're very lucky.
- Yeah.
If you're half Japanese and
have a Japanese passport,
it's gonna be easy to move here.
- Easy move, baby.
- For anyone else who's
thinking about moving to Japan,
whatever visa you're
thinking about coming on,
it is going to be-
- It's hell, yeah.
- It's tough.
- And this year or this
year from, oh, sorry,
from April this year I
believe they changed the rules
to make visas more or easier to get
because they need more
immigrants to work here
because the population is getting older.
And they allocated 40,000 worker permits.
And in the article, they only
managed to allocate 4,000
this year of the 40,000.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Wait, it's 40,000 per year?
- For some specific kind of visa
for this year I think or something
and they only managed to do 1/10th of that
which is like not a problem
because I don't think there's like,
there's not demand to move here.
This is probably one of the countries
that I think people have most interest
in moving to out of a lot of places.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And it's just, I think
that if anything says a lot
about how difficult it is to move here.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Oh, yeah.
- I mean, I can't speak on
any other visa processes,
but you know?
- Everyone I've talked to
has had a difficult process
unless you're just coming
here for a tourist visa.
- Super easy.
- Just walk in, literally just turn up.
- Or if you're one of those countries
that has working holiday visa.
- Yeah.
- Which unfortunately America does not.
So sorry Americans.
- Yeah, if you want advice
on how to move here easily
get a working holiday visa.
It's probably gonna be-
- I think those last a year and a half?
- Is it a year and a half?
- I think it depends on the country.
At least Australians
have a year and a half.
- Wow.
- I don't know about UK,
maybe UK has like six months
to a year maybe, depends.
- Yeah.
- A lot of paperwork we had to fill out.
- Yeah, I think the
hardest part of the process
was finding an apartment.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, I'm a Japanese citizen
and it was still a pain in
the ass for me to do it.
- You hear about on YouTube
and Twitter and everything
like it's hard, it's hard.
And then you see some people saying like,
"Yeah, people are over exaggerating."
It is 100% hard.
- No, it's hard.
- It is fucking difficult.
- Especially if you're
a foreigner as well.
You basically play under different rules.
It's sad to say like you know,
and you kind of think if you have money,
you get an apartment.
- I think more importantly,
especially if you're a YouTuber-
- Oh my God.
- Oh God.
- Because the hardest
thing, at least in Japan,
from my experience about why it's so hard
to get a fucking apartment here is
because freelancing is not a job here.
- Yeah.
- Freelancing,
you might as well be unemployed
according to this government's-
- The government's like
that typical Asian parent.
- Yeah.
- Who's like, "What?
You're not a doctor or
an engineer or a lawyer?"
Get out of here.
- You're unemployed, right?
You're working part time.
- And that's due to,
because they're worried
about if you can pay all whatnot.
- Yeah.
- Right.
But the thing is, is that
they don't even like,
you know, at least in like,
I don't know about the UK
or Thailand, but at least in Australia,
when you sign up for
like an apartment, right?
Usually the landlord will be like,
"Okay, can I see your bank account?"
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like just to see how much money
you have saved up, you know?
Regardless of what job you
do, we just want to see
that you have money in
the bank and if you do,
then you're like okay.
But here in Japan, they
don't check your bank.
They check your work status to make sure
that there's like a constant
flow of money coming in.
- And it's not just that as well,
'cause if you're not Japanese
and especially if you
can't speak Japanese,
most places aren't even gonna
talk to you or consider you.
'Cause that was a big problem we had
because we went through an agency
and we just made a list of
about 10 to 20 apartments
that we were interested in.
And we sent it off and applied-
- Rejected from all of them.
- Jesus Christ.
- And we had a company as a guarantor
so having the payments
secured wasn't the issue.
It was like a lot of the time
it was really dumb stuff.
Like can you sort the bins
properly and stuff like that.
- It's like yes, we're not 12 year olds.
- It's like the main concern
you'll hear all the time
is can you sort your trash properly?
And it's like, okay, it might be different
from where I'm from but like-
- I can learn.
- Yeah.
It's like the government
councils in the area
give you an English manual
that tells you how to do it.
It is tedious and it is a lot more complex
than most places, but it's not like-
- It's not rocket science.
- Yeah, it's not like you're having to do
the weirdest stuff
imaginable to this stuff.
Like it's basically just rinse your stuff,
separate all of it, that's pretty much it.
And I know there's some places in Europe
that do it way more thorough
that probably don't have this concern
when they're letting people rent houses.
It's just like-
- Because it's the least of your concerns.
It's, you know?
Yeah. It's ridiculous.
- Yeah and the thing is that
if you go through an agency,
for example, that
specializes in foreigners
and people who can't speak Japanese,
you're gonna be paying
so much more as well.
- Yeah, you pay a premium for that bill.
- You pay like a premium
for that bill and that rent.
So you either have a
fucking difficult time
finding a place and getting
past all the barriers
or you're just gonna
pay a shit ton of money
and those aren't two very good options.
- Yeah.
The only concern that they often cite,
building managers, etc,
that I find is like somewhat,
all right, that's fair enough,
is their worried that you'll run away,
run away and not pay the rent.
But if you have a guarantor,
that's the whole fucking point
of that problem, which-
- You can't run away.
- If you run away, you're
still getting your money
and the house is vacant.
Great, no damage to it.
This is a win-win for the company.
I don't understand.
You play by their rules in every way.
- It's because it's just like typical,
this is like one aspect
of Japanese work culture
that I learned very quickly is that
it doesn't matter what the business is.
If they're not 100000000% sure
that this is going to go through,
it might as well be 0%.
- No risk, yeah, they don't risk here.
- There's no risk in any business venture,
whether that be paying
for rent or anything,
it's like if they not 100000000% sure
in every possible avenue ever,
it's just not happening.
And you know, it's ridiculous.
- I think that'd be interesting
to talk about later on
when we get to more of the stuff
that we've experienced here,
but was there any part of the
visa process applying for it,
'cause I'm sure people are
wondering, I got a lot of emails.
I'm sure you did as well.
People asking, "Hey,
how did you get a visa?
Was it hard?"
Et cetera, et cetera.
If there's any advice you can give someone
who's watching who wants to come to Japan,
what would you say is like
the main piece of advice?
If they want to get a working visa?
- I mean, I didn't
apply for a working visa
so I don't have too
much experience with it.
- We didn't apply for it.
We had an immigration lawyers help us.
- Yeah. We had immigration
lawyers help us,
but I mean, I've applied for visas before.
And the worst, the most
painful part is just waiting.
- And you're gonna be waiting a lot.
- You're gonna be waiting a long time
and you're just gonna be
in this limbo kind of-
- 'Cause we had what?
It was like the initial
thing where they file
for something called a
Certificate of Eligibility
which is basically if
the government decides
if you can have a visa,
which isn't the visa itself,
which already sounds to me like,
that sounds like we're adding steps
where steps don't need to be.
But as you move to Japan,
you'll learn that's what they love to do.
So yeah, we had to wait, what was it?
Six weeks for that, six to eight weeks?
- Yeah, six to eight weeks.
- It could have been six to eight weeks
for this piece of paper to arrive,
which then they send by post
which makes you feel so uneasy
because you're like they're
sending me a piece of paper
through the mail that
I've waited two months for
and you're just like
something's gonna go wrong.
Someone's gonna take it.
So you get this piece of paper, right?
To get this thing you need to prove
that you have a good
reason to work in Japan,
that the job or, you know,
'cause you have to say what your work is.
They need to check that
you are actually in that
field, et cetera, et cetera.
- We had to send so much evidence
that we were doing
valuable work that could-
- Which I'm sure some people would argue
YouTube isn't, but you know?
At the end of the day,
if we bring in money
to the government and pay taxes,
it's valuable work, right?
- Yeah, basically just how many
companies we've worked with,
what's work that's notable that-
- And then why we need to be in Japan
to do more work.
- What it felt like was
I was applying for a job.
It was like here's all my achievements.
Here's what I can bring for your country.
Please, please, please-
- Let me play on your team, coach.
(guys laughing)
And then yeah, so we get that
Certificate of Eligibility,
which is we get that.
And then you have to go to the embassy.
- So you turn that into a visa
and then they'll put a-
- Yeah, which again, there's more steps
'cause first of all,
if you live in the UK,
the only embassy is in London.
Now I would feel bad for someone
who lives in the North of Scotland.
I don't think they have
an Embassy in Scotland.
- No, no.
- In Wales, I had to go all
the way from Wales that,
I mean, luckily there's
fast train, doesn't matter.
But point is one embassy,
so you're going to be taking
a day trip to get this thing.
Worst part is, is that then
if you go to the embassy,
which you might've have to
traveled to across country for,
you have to wait five days
to then actually get the visa
which is a little thing
they just print out
and staple in your passport.
- So you have to go back to the embassy.
- Yeah. You have to go back, right?
So I just went home,
'cause I'm like not staying
in London for five days.
If you're poor, you haven't got much money
and you can't, you know,
the train tickets in the
UK are expensive, right?
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of things
where it's just like, my God,
why are we doing this?
- But then again like realistically,
how many people in the butt
fuck middle of Scotland
is going to apply for a visa-
- I'm sure, I bet there's one person from
like the North Island in like Scotland,
who's like, "Dude, I had
a fly, fuck that shit."
- If you are that one
person watching, subscribe.
(guys laughing)
- And to make matters even more stressful,
you lost your passport.
- I did.
- You lost your passport.
- This mother, we were
meeting up at the embassy
to collect our visas
and this mother fucker lost his passport.
- When I heard that story,
I couldn't fucking believe.
- Oh my God.
That was like one of the
worst days of my life.
- Like you can't write that shit.
- I know, it was horrible.
- All because you didn't
have a fucking backpack.
- I carry my passport in my jeans pocket,
which I'm hearing people like oh my God.
- The worst!
- Oh my God!
- The worst idea.
- I'm like cringing hearing that, man.
I'm like.
- So okay, I've traveled
like all over the world
just having my passport in my pocket.
Okay, I have lost it before
and you guys know I have.
I lost it in America as well.
I found it though luckily, but anyway,
so I was going to the train
station to go to the train,
go to London.
And as my train arrived, I
always tap my pockets, right,
just to make sure it's there.
I tap my pockets.
It's not in there, it's not I'm there.
And I'm like fuck.
And what's running through my head is
all of this months of work,
I feel bad for the company,
they paid for lawyers.
All these people who
have banked on me coming
and I've put so much work into this,
myself and other people.
And I was like having a mental breakdown.
I don't think I've ever had that much
of a quick mental breakdown in my life.
- Yeah.
It's to be expected.
- And it was like gradually getting worse
in the hour I couldn't find it.
I scoured this train station,
a tiny train station in Wales.
It's called Flint.
You can look it up.
It's literally just like a platform.
There's no where this should have gone
where I couldn't have found it, right?
Could not find it.
Check my car, quickly drove
home to find it, didn't find it.
Came back to check
again, couldn't find it.
Go in to the police station.
Literally everything.
I could not find my passport.
- So you have no idea what happened to it?
- I have no idea what
happened to my passport.
And then eventually it was
getting like three, 4:00 pm
and I was like, okay,
I'm gonna just call up
the British government and tell them,
hey, can you just cancel my passport.
I wanna apply for another one.
And that whole thing was an ordeal.
And then my main concern
was like, all right,
well, I lost my passport.
Do I have to restart the
whole visa process again?
Luckily the embassy were like,
"No, as long as you have the certificate",
which I didn't lose.
Great. I could redo it.
- You lucky fucker.
- I had to scramble to get a new passport
and that was a whole thing.
And I got one within
like five days luckily.
And luckily it all went well,
but it was just so stressful
on top of already the stress that,
I was already at my limit with stress
that whole period, because
of this whole thing
and that was just like the full,
I had a full breakdown that that day.
That was horrible.
And I think I like joked
about it on Twitter,
but like I was like not okay that day.
- Oh yeah.
- No, no, no.
- And the worst part is, right,
is when you fuck up this badly,
you can accept that yo fucked up
but it's messaging your
friends being like,
"Hey, I'm not gonna be
in London in two hours."
They're like, "Oh, why, what's up?"
I'm like, "I lost my passport."
(guys laughing)
- I remember reading that text,
'cause I was waiting for
you outside the embassy
when you were like, I get a
message from Connor being like,
"I'm gonna be a bit like 30 minutes late."
(guys laughing)
- Little did I know.
- Was like oh, all
right, I'll get a coffee.
And I see the event unfold
as he's just texting me.
So he goes, "Yeah, I
can't find my passport.
I'm just gonna go look for it quickly."
And then it was just you
like just breaking down
every message and it just ends with,
"Yeah, I don't think I can come."
- And I'm still annoyed to this day
because I went around,
this is a very small town where I lost it.
I went around like
every shop in that area.
I asked literally everyone in that area.
Hey, if you find this passport,
can you call me right away?
Because if not, I'm gonna
just cancel it today.
I still never heard anything.
I was crazy and I don't
know how I lost it.
- So from your experience
for anyone who's listening
if there's anything they need to know
to make the process easier,
what would you guys say?
- Get a degree.
- Yeah, a degree helps a
lot, especially if it's-
- Not an associate's,
like a bachelor's degree.
- Yeah, I think a lot of their forms
didn't recognize associate's.
I think it actually said, it's
specified like bachelor's.
- I don't think associates
is a thing in Japan.
- It's not a thing in
the UK, I don't think.
- Yeah, it's not a thing.
- It's not a thing in Japan, right?
I mean, it is a thing,
but like it's not as heavily emphasized
on as a bachelor's degree.
- I saw a lot of people are asking like,
Oh, how do we get it, et cetera.
You need to have, especially
with a country that's strict,
you need to have concrete proof
that you can do something here.
You can't just come here on a whim.
- That you're worth something.
- Unless you are like
extremely, extremely rich
and they want your tax money
I think the only other reason,
like you need some good reason.
- Even then you need a
degree for something anyway.
- They'll find a way to-
- Yeah, 'cause then they'll be like,
"Where are you getting
this money from, bro?"
- And I imagine just having
like a fair amount of experience
in what you're doing
and the reason for coming
here will help a ton.
I mean, I can't talk about most,
just what we went through.
- Or basically just come
here to teach English.
- That is like the instant get in button.
- Yeah. Pretty much.
It's like I can speak English
and I can teach it somewhat
then they're like you're hired.
- It's probably not a bad way to,
if your goal ultimately is
living in Japan forever,
it's probably not a bad way to
transition into living here.
- No, because I know a
lot of friends personally
who did start off with teaching English
and then gradually moved
on to something else.
- 'Cause by teaching English,
you can gain connections in the country
and then maybe that transitions
to an like a normal office
job or something like that
or working with a company.
But if you just want to get
your foot through the door,
I think teaching English
would be the easiest way
for anyone to be able to do it.
But you still need a degree.
- Yeah, I agree, you need a degree.
- But they pretty much
accept everyone on that,
as far as I'm aware as long as,
again, if you have a degree.
- Yeah, It doesn't matter how good
your high school essays were.
If you don't have a degree in that, yeah.
- Which is why I'm so glad
to drop out of university.
- Listen to your Asian parents, go to uni
if you want to go to Japan.
- You guys have all got degrees, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
- Engineering baby, let's go.
- Oh really?
- Yeah. Engineering.
- I never actually have known what degree,
you have an engineering degree, right?
- I have.
- Yeah, he has an electrical engineering
and I have mechanical engineering.
- Oh, wow.
- But he has a master's,
I have a bachelor's.
- I got a fucking master's mother fucker.
(guys laughing)
- Look at this boy spending
more than four years at uni.
- I got to the third year,
I was like, I can't do it anymore.
I can't do this.
I gotta get out, I gotta get out.
- Connor's like have I
got the required minimum?
Yeah. Get me out of here.
(guys laughing)
I don't want to be here
for another year, dude.
- So now that you guys moved to Japan,
what would you say are the pros and cons
of actually living here?
- I mean, I want to know
from you guys, right?
Because I mean, I've experienced Japan
pretty much for half my life so I know,
to me the pros and cons are
just very natural to me.
- And I feel like you,
the most of the cons
that we might, me and Garnt might have,
you won't ever experience because one,
you can speak the language
and read it fluently.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I don't know, man, I have
the face of a foreigner.
- Yeah, true.
- Like I'm just gonna say it.
There's a lot of discrimination here.
(guys laughing)
- But I mean, what country doesn't?
- I would say, I like understand it more
because growing up in an Asian country,
there's definitely discrimination in Asia.
It's just very different from
what you see in the West.
I think.
- That's the thing,
it's not racism.
It's more xenophobia.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Right, and if you guys
don't know the difference
between that, racism is where it's like,
oh, you're a different race to me
so therefore you are worse than me.
And xenophobia is like,
oh, you're not from here
therefore you're, you know?
- I think it comes more
from a place of ignorance.
- It's just ignorance I think.
- 'Cause it's just, you know,
'cause you guys didn't
open the country for ages.
- I mean, Japan has been a closed island
for like the past 2000 years, right?
- Exactly.
- So it's like,
what do you expect?
- Exactly.
So it makes sense to me.
But like for example,
finding an apartment,
that was my first experience with that
where if you didn't,
if you're not Japanese
and if you didn't speak Japanese
then they were very scared
to even touch you, you know?
Or even consider you in that case.
- Especially when you have
a company backing you.
In my mind, I was like,
I don't see what the problem is here.
I'm like the model tenant here.
I'm single.
- The problem is we can't
write your name in Kanji.
- Yeah, right?
- That's the problem.
- Kata Connor name? Ew, gross.
- But I mean, I have a problem too,
because even though I am Japanese
and I have a Japanese name,
the fact that I don't look it,
is already a huge wall
that regular Japanese
people find a difficulty
in getting over because,
it's really funny as well,
because during my intern days as well,
I had to be the guy to like
if there was like a business
partner coming to the office,
I had to be the one to
get on the phone with them
and being like, "Okay, you
guys are coming at this time
and this day, okay, I'll
come down to meet you guys
and greet you up to the office."
But when I speak Japanese,
I don't have an accent
and my name is Japanese.
So there were so many
times where I would go down
to greet them and they'd
be like who the fuck-
(guys laughing)
She's like, "You're not the
person on the phone, right?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I am."
And it's like, "Oh, Oh, we
thought you were Japanese."
And I'm like, "I am Japanese."
And they're like.
To so many of like the older
generation, especially,
they just can't fathom that there are
these things called hafus.
It's just not a thing.
It's like you're either
Japanese or you're not Japanese.
- Yeah.
'Cause the way I it is that,
I treat it like exactly the same
how I would treat my
grandmother or my granddad
who lived in Thailand
in this small village
their entire fucking life,
knew nothing about the outside world.
So they just didn't know.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's the same way with
a lot of Japanese people
where some of them,
especially like older people
who've never interacted with a foreigner
or even like got to
know them or even knows
what the outside world is like
beyond what they see on the
news and what they see on TV.
You know what I mean?
- And you don't want
to like input anything
from Japanese TV.
- No, no, you don't.
- My god.
Some of the stuff they air is like-
- We're called Trash Taste Podcast.
If there's anything trashier
than Trash Taste Podcast
it is fucking Japanese TV.
It is full of absolute garbage.
- Yeah.
- It's something I wish that
like a lot of YouTubers whose channel
is focused all about Japan
would speak about it a little more.
'Cause it's not something you can ignore.
Like if you're foreign or even
look foreign and live here,
you're gonna experience it like totally.
And I didn't know anything about this
because no YouTubers talk
about it or anything.
And I feel like it's
such an important topic
especially when you talk
about living in Japan,
it's gonna be a factor,
you're gonna be stared at.
And it's not like you've said,
it's not a place of
like hatred or anything.
It's just like they don't
see kind of people a lot.
- I think the problem
was a lot of J-Vloggers
that do cover the topics like that,
'cause when you live here,
you pretty much get to
know every J-Vlogger.
It's just natural, it's
such a small community.
So I know pretty much every
like notable J-Vlogger here.
And there's been a number
of them that I know
that have made topics on
the blatant xenophobia
here in Japan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But the problem is I
think a lot of those videos
aren't taken seriously by the internet
because it's seen as like
a privileged problem.
It's like you get to
live in Japan, you know?
So therefore you should just be able
to put up with this shit, right?
Because you get to experience
all this other cool stuff.
When that's not the point
of the video, right?
Like it's still a problem
regardless of how privileged
you may seem living here.
- I think the worst
thing that happened to me
was the time, one time we
got the police called on us.
- Oh, yeah.
- Do you wanna explain why
we got the police called?
We didn't do anything illegal.
We just played Mario Party really loud.
- Yeah at like two in the morning.
(guys laughing)
Very drunk.
- That was our bad.
We can't really complain about that.
Okay, so basically we've
got a noise complaint.
So the policeman came and
he basically asked Joey,
who is he with?
- Yeah.
- And I remember you saying like,
"Oh, there's one American,
one British person."
And then there was me, who I'm Thai.
So he mentioned that
I'm with a Thai friend.
And as soon as he mentioned
that he was with a Thai friend,
the policeman was like, "Oh."
- "Can we see your Thai friend?"
And I go up there and I
started getting grilled
about why I'm here.
They want to see my
passport and everything.
And they asked me for my visa.
- But you showed them your
British passport, right?
- No, as soon I was like,
"Oh, I have a British passport though."
They were like, "Okay, you're free to go."
(guys laughing)
- It was so messed up.
- And I was like, "Oh, what
the fuck just happened?
What was that?"
- It was so messed up.
And the fact that they
only called you up there,
even though there was like,
it was like the most multicultural room
in probably the entire apartment building.
- I'm gonna say it now.
I wasn't making the noise.
(guys laughing)
- You were like the
quietest there, if anything.
And that was the first time
I ever experienced that too.
And I'm just like, Jesus Christ,
like they couldn't even
be subtle about it.
- No, no, no.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like you do know like
this is like not cool, right?
But to them it's just, you know?
- I think you just, I don't know.
I know I get starred at a
lot which is weird for me
because obviously coming
from like the whitest place on earth,
I was just like another person.
And I've never experienced
this in my life,
which I guess is also strange.
And also,
this is gonna sound so
odd, but okay, in Japan,
not exactly known for the best
legal system, if you will.
- Okay.
- Normally if you're arrested
or whatever or convicted,
charged with a crime,
you normally get like,
it's like a 98, 99% conviction rate.
- I don't know where this is going but-
- Right, but also this is
the first time I've ever been
around police where I'm like, shit,
please don't stop me,
Please don't stop me.
(guys laughing)
I guess this is like Connor
checking his white privilege
for the first time ever.
But like, because if the
police stop me, right?
I can't explain to them why I might,
like I don't know what
I might do that's wrong.
You know what I mean?
I don't wanna get fucking arrested
'cause like how do I get
myself out of that hole?
- Right.
- And then, yeah, it's just
a weird experience for me
that I've never felt before.
And I'm sure people are like, wow, Connor,
really seeing his white
privilege for the first time ever
in his life.
But it's weird though, right?
'Cause that's like stuff
that I never considered
I'd have after like worry about ever.
- Right, you have to like
kind of experience it
unfortunately firsthand to
fully understand it, right?
And that's the problem is
that there are so many,
like, I guess, controversial
topics like that
concerning being a
foreigner, living in Japan
that I'm sure a lot of
J-Vloggers want to talk about,
but because from the
position that they're talking
about it for them, it's
very difficult to make-
- Hard to bring it up like,
oh, they hate Chinese people.
- Right, because it's
also like for someone,
for a foreigner who's never lived in Japan
it's very hard to like swallow
and understand being like,
no, that doesn't happen, right?
That must be just you.
Whereas it's very much a common occurrence
for any like foreigner who
lives here unfortunately.
- It's unfortunate, but it's just a thing
where you move here and
you realize there's-
- Pretty quickly.
- Yeah, pretty quickly
that it works differently
and people view you differently as well.
But I think to me, that is
the worst experience I've had
about moving to Japan apart from, okay.
Can we talk about how slow
Japanese businesses work?
- Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- My fucking god.
Everyone has this image that
Japan this like super tech-
- Optimized place, the most
optimized system on earth.
They figured it out.
- Speed running business.
- Things just work.
You go to a restaurant, you
press a button on a tablet
and the food just appears in front of you.
You're like this is the future.
And then you go to a Japanese business
and you're like, "Oh,
is that a fax machine?
Are you using a fax machine right now?"
(laughing)
- Or just like stuff you
never even considered
a problem or asking for permission
for the slightest thing on earth.
It's just like you show a
logo or something in a video,
we got to find permission to do that.
It's like just fucking upload it.
If it's a problem,
they'll tell us, you know?
- See, but that's the thing, right?
Is that Japan doesn't understand-
- No risk.
- Well, no risk as well
but at least with like
what we do business wise,
Japan doesn't have fair use.
- No, yeah.
- So it's so difficult to
get permission for any,
like if you ask like as you said,
it's like can I just show
this logo of your company
that is like publicly
available to anybody?
Just like slap it on for like two seconds.
I'm not even gonna mention
your name, just slap it on.
It has to go through like 100 layers
of the company just to get a simple yes.
And that could take like a
couple of days if you're lucky,
usually a week to maybe a month.
And it's just like ugh.
- It's a business model
where there's like,
imagine if every employee was a boss
and everyone had to ask
for permission constantly.
It's like employees can't
make their own decisions.
They have to ask their boss
who then asks their boss
and their boss and that takes a week.
And that's just to see
if you can sharpen your pencil, right?
We haven't got to business yet.
Like we're just trying to figure out
what the fuck's happening.
- It's not even just business.
It's just signing up for-
- Everything.
- It's everything.
Everything moves so slowly.
I remember when we signed
up for our gym membership.
- Oh my God.
- It took us an hour-
- An hour and a half I think.
- An hour and a half to
sign up for a fucking,
to get a gym card, right?
'Cause you know in America
or like basically everywhere
where you get the terms
and conditions, right?
You fucking scroll
through, you click accept.
No, in Japan, you're gonna sit there
and you're gonna read every term
and you're gonna agree to every
fucking term individually.
And they're gonna sit there with you
to make sure you read it all.
(guys laughing)
- Yeah, you're not only
subject to going through
the fine print, which is no longer fine,
it's just print.
But they're like, "Let
me read it out for you
in case you're a fucking
illiterate piece of shit."
It's like no, see that's
why like when I signed up
for the gym membership
because it's all written
in Japanese, right?
I straight up just said
like, "I can read it."
(guys laughing)
I saved myself like an hour
of pain of just like listening
to this fucking hour long
monologue from this like-
- I think that's 'cause we are foreign,
he was like, he really,
really wanted to make sure
we understood and bear in mind
these weren't terms and conditions
of any like social things.
It was like literally the
bare bones of what a gym
needs to make sure you know.
like don't run on the treadmill
if your legs don't work, right?
Just stuff like, basically
don't sue us stuff, right?
Stuff you wouldn't take for granted.
And I remember he was like asking us,
our translator, if we
understood every single point,
and every one of them was like,
"Do you understand that on the treadmill
you have to have your hands on
the treadmill at all times?"
And I looked at like our friend Nabby,
and I was like, "Is he serious?"
It's not a joke, right?
He wants me to like agree-
- He legally has to say that.
- I have to agree that
I'm gonna put my hands on,
have you ever seen like anyone,
like a crippled old man
run on the treadmill?
- Oh yes, because that's how I run,
just like free hands.
- No one does that and
you're literally like,
you're signing this agreement
and you turn your head to see
10 people on the treadmill,
none of them holding their hands.
And you're like, "Yes, I agree."
It's just, it's all bullshit.
That's all you do.
And this is the stuff
that you never experience
as a tourist, because it's
like perfectly separate
the stuff that you
experienced as a tourist
to the stuff you experienced living here.
And the moment you do something
that is remotely permanent
or reoccurring in a contract,
you better be ready to
bring every document
that you've ever had in your life
and the hanko which you'll lose a lot.
- I'm surprised they didn't ask
for our fucking birth certificate
when signing up for the gym,
because it's so formal with everything.
It's like, you don't need
to know my life story.
- That's the perfect word.
Everything in Japan is so formal
and you don't see it as a tourist,
'cause when you're here
in Japan on tourism
and you're just sight seeing,
everything just works, right?
You go to a restaurant, it just works.
Living here, all the little intricacies
and all the little things
you take for granted
that should be quick,
just takes a million processes
when it's just the most
un-optimized thing in the world.
And there's just a lot of
things that don't make sense
in contracts, like going
back to paying rent.
There's this thing called a key fee.
What was it like?
- The fucking, this is the most obnoxious,
it's like key money, right?
- Key money.
- And I mean, you can
explain it if you want.
Go ahead.
But it's the most
obnoxious thing on earth.
- What can I explain?
- It's two months of rent, sometimes.
- So the amount is
about two months of rent
that you pay to the rent
owner to say thank you
for renting me your place.
- For free, you don't get it back.
- It's not a deposit, you
just pay two months of rent.
- Which you also have to
pay a deposit and then.
- Yeah, on top of the
deposit that you have to pay.
- It's basically a dick suck fee.
That's what it is.
It's like, thank you so much
for letting me stay in your apartment.
That's what it is.
- And then it doesn't end there
because you then have to pay the rental,
the agency that got you the house,
you have to pay a month's
rent to them as a fee,
which is just stupid because I
think in every other country,
they take that split from
the person renting the house.
Not from you because renting
a house shouldn't be,
you shouldn't have to pay like
six to eight months upfront.
That's ridiculous.
And I think it's the reason
why a lot of homeless people
here also struggle to get housing
because how the fuck are
you gonna get six months
worth of rent and money?
Are you kidding me?
Like that's insane.
- When you look at the
rent you expect like, okay,
this is how much I'm gonna
pay for the first month.
- I pay a deposit, maybe two months.
- Yeah, like maybe like
a month or two deposit,
but like no, it's like
double or triple that.
And I'm just like, Jesus Christ.
- It's ridiculous.
- Yeah, stupid.
- It's like, yeah, six months
worth of rent in one sitting.
And you're not gonna get two
months of that back at all.
- Because they want you
to stay in that apartment.
They don't want you to leave.
And I like going around.
I like moving, getting a new place,
seeing how things are, knowing
what I like and don't like,
but now it's pretty much just solidified
that I'm not leaving this
because I'm gonna charge
out the ass if I wanna move.
- Because it's like a minimum of two years
to stay in one place.
- Two years, yeah.
And even then if you're moving,
like the amount that you
paid in that first month,
that if you split that
across two years of rent,
it'd be way over paying for what you got.
- Oh yeah.
I think that's why,
that's one thing, right?
About like living in
Japan that I've personally
never understood for the longest time.
But I think finally now I do understand
is when people say like,
"Man, Japan is such an expensive place."
But when you think about it, it's like no,
cause when I think, "Oh, Japan
is such an expensive place",
I think like-
- Eating out, drinking.
- Eating out or drinking.
And I'm like, no, it's relatively cheap.
But then you think about-
- All the bills.
- Six months worth of rent
in the first month kind of bullshit.
And I'm like, okay, maybe, yeah,
it is a little bit
ridiculous and expensive.
- Yeah. I mean, you
can live frugally here.
It's not too hard to live frugally.
- No, you can live cheap.
It's like not a problem.
I mean, konbinis you can live off.
- Yeah, oh my God.
- We can do a whole episode.
- But that's basically the
best thing about Japan, right?
Like no matter where you are,
you are in with like 100 meter radius
of everything you need
like no questions asked.
- Japan is the only country
where the word convenience store
actually lives up to its name
because it is actually one
of the most convenient places
that you could go.
- God, I love konbini
so fucking much, man.
- Like not even the
food, the food's amazing.
Like you expect this, like
if you go to a gas station
in any country in the world
and you try and convince
me to buy something
that's been cooked in that building,
I would rather like just get salmonella.
I'm not gonna risk
seeing what they give me.
You know what I mean?
Those nasty hot dogs that
have been in rotation
for like 20 hours at least.
But the one thing that I thought was just
the most genius thing that Japan does,
which I do not understand
why every other country
doesn't do this, is the
fact that they just have
a printing machine in there.
- Oh, a printer, yeah.
- So no one needs to
buy a printer or buy it,
you can just go to this place
that's probably within 100 meters of you,
200 meters at most.
- Max.
- Yeah.
- You pay like 10 cents or whatever
and you can get a printed
A4 copy of whatever you want
because no one needs to
print that much shit, right?
I've never needed to print
more than like one document.
- And ink's fucking expensive.
- Right? And it dries as well.
So you might print one
thing, it's gone dry.
And I feel so bad for
admitting that I've done this
but in the UK, in university,
when we had to have a printer
and I was printing a of documents,
I used to like, the ink
was more expensive to buy
on its own than just buying a new printer.
- Yeah.
- So every time I ran out of ink,
I bought a new printer.
(guys laughing)
- Are you serious?
- Yeah.
- That's like 200 IQ move though.
- Yeah, I know, right?
- Bear in mind, right,
this is the time when
you're in university, right?
Where losing 20 pounds,
which is like like 30 bucks at the time,
was like a big deal, right?
You don't get any money.
I can't afford to lose 30 bucks.
- That's like 10 instant ramens, dude.
- Right, that's like two
nights out if I'm good.
So I would go to like the charity shop
and just give it to them.
And every single month on cue,
I'd come in with a printer
and just the exact same Amazon
basics printer and give it.
And I just thought like I can
appreciate this so much now
that in Japan if you
want to print anything,
you don't have to buy a printer,
you don't have to fuck
around worrying about
which ink cartridge
matched with your printer.
You just go to the convenience
store and you print it off.
And it's just like, it makes sense.
- And the best thing is if
you do need to print out
a document or anything,
you can just be like,
oh, I can do that,
but you know, I can also buy a drink.
- Yeah, yeah, at the same time, right?
- Or I can stock up my
fridge. It's all there.
- I can pay my bills.
You can pay your bills.
- That's the best thing,
you can pay your bills at-
- The convenience store, yeah.
- That's wild to me.
- It's insane.
- I don't anymore because
that just takes time
but I did at first.
It was a novelty at first.
- 'Cause I think the best
and worst part of Japan to me
is that it's like a dichotomy,
it either works exceedingly well,
it's well exceedingly optimized,
or it's just 100 processes
to do the simplest shit.
There's no middle ground.
Nothing here works okay.
It either works exceedingly well
or it just doesn't work at all.
- I think it's normally
like a public demand, right?
Convenience stores, trains.
Everyone is using them 24/7.
We want this easy as
possible, (indistinct),
all that, it all works flawlessly.
- Yeah.
- I think where it comes
into play mostly is with
government agencies,
big companies that have higher ups
that don't want to change
things very fastly.
And if you thought like
companies in the West
don't want to change things, my God,
you are in for like a surprise.
- Most Japanese companies haven't changed
since like the 70s.
- Because not only do they
not want to change things,
even if the person before them dies,
they're like, "Well, they
didn't want to change it
and I really don't want
to step on their toes,
even though they don't exist anymore."
It's like, we've got to keep
everything the same way it was
that's been working.
- That's the problem though
is Japan has such a double edged sword
in terms of like maintaining culture.
- It does.
- Yeah, it works in great ways.
- And maintaining tradition
is the word I was looking for, yeah.
- It's very traditional in
a lot of ways like, man,
I'm looking at Japanese web design.
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God, man.
- I take it for granted
how good we had it.
I didn't realize that I
cared about user interface.
- I was interning, I was in
the web division department
because that's what I
majored in at uni, right?
So I had to like go around fixing
basically clients old websites
and anybody who ever did
anything like HTML or CSS related
can relate to this.
But I almost had a stroke when
I looked at the source code
and I saw a table
(guys laughing)
and I'm like, that's
something we haven't used
since like the early 90s.
This is like early 90s type of web design
and they're still using it to this day.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't think I've
seen a single animation
on a webpage in Japan.
- No.
- There's no graphics at all.
It literally looks like the
first windows iteration.
- It just looks so fucking cluttered.
- Yeah.
- Weirdly enough,
the best web design I have seen
is landing pages for new anime.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the only good
websites that I've seen.
I'm like damn.
They used JavaScript for the shit, Jesus.
- Before we move on to the logistics,
I want to talk about staying to the pros,
how good the fucking food is here, man.
- Oh my God.
- Moving here from England.
- Where good food is you either,
it's you either have to pay a lot
or you have to cook it yourself.
Everything here tastes good.
It's just true, right?
You never have a bad
experience in Japan with food.
I swear to God.
- That's like the difference
that I tell my parents the most,
I'm like in the UK, I
don't know about Australia,
but when you go to the
restaurant, it's not a gamble,
but it kind of is.
You don't know if it's
gonna be okay or amazing.
And it's always a coin flip.
You just don't know.
And you have to go to find out-
- Oh no, that's 100% how
it works in Australia.
- 'Cause it might just
be a restaurant owned
by a guy who has no idea what he's doing.
He doesn't give a shit about the food.
But in Japan it is like guaranteed
no matter where you go,
you will get good food.
- Yeah.
- You are never overcharged either.
You always pay a fair amount.
- And when you are overcharged,
it is like the taste and
experience is worth it.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- I remember saying very
harsh words to my mom
when she used to just, you know,
I'm like how dare you give me
this bland food all my life
when this stuff existed.
How many times must I have
beans and toast, mother?
How many times can a
man eat beans and toast?
I actually still like beans and toast.
- When the konbini food here is better
than a lot of the restaurant food
you can find in British
restaurants I go to,
I'm like, man, there's
something wrong from here.
There's something wrong here, man.
- That's the insane thing is that
I don't know if Japan is the
only country that's like this
but it's cheaper to eat out
than it is to cook your own food.
- It's the same thing in Thailand.
- I think a lot of the Asian
countries are like that, yeah.
- Okay, because at least in
Australia, like Jesus Christ,
no one goes to restaurants
because it's like,
I don't want to gamble if this $25 pasta
is gonna be good or not like I'm sorry.
I'm like I'm not that rich.
I'd rather just go to a supermarket
and just cook a $5 pasta myself.
- Here in Japan and to
get like a single lime,
a single lime,
I pay $2.
$2 for a single fucking lime.
What the fuck!
- I don't think anyone's
mentioned that on YouTube.
People don't tell you how
expensive it is to cook here.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if this is just like,
maybe in America it's different.
We're not from America
and I know the prices
for fresh food in America
is like ridiculous.
- Yeah.
- But in the UK, I don't
know about Australia,
in the UK buying ingredients
is so incredibly cheap.
- Same in Australia, yeah.
- Which is why nobody,
eating out is not so much
you do it for the food.
It's more of like an
experience with your friends.
It's not for an event, right?
- It's a luxury.
- Yeah, it's a luxury.
- You don't do it because
like you have the money.
It's like you do it for a reason.
If you speak to someone in the UK
and I know that if you say
like you eat out every day
in the UK, everyone's like
what's the fuck wrong with you?
- Yeah, because it in the UK,
you don't eat out alone, right?
It's very rare to do something
like eating out alone.
And here, more people eat out
alone then cook, you know?
Because it's just more convenient
and it's cheaper as well.
'Cause my God, vegetables
here, meats are okay,
but vegetables are so expensive.
- I don't know why.
And the biggest offender in
my mind, limes, terrible,
peppers, you know like
normal bell peppers?
- Yeah.
- In the UK, I distinctly
remember in like Aldi
or even Tesco, it's like
one pound 29, right,
for a pack of three bell peppers, right?
That's like what, $1.60.
In Japan for like a single bell pepper,
which comes with its own packaging,
it's like 180 yen.
So if you want to have three peppers.
- It's like two bucks.
- So that's two bucks.
- It's like $6 for three bell peppers.
Are you fucking kidding me?
- Can we talk about the
biggest offender though,
which is fruit?
- Oh my God.
- Fruits-
- Okay, they're good, they're good,
first of all, they're good.
- They're amazing.
- They're good.
- But Jesus, talk about overpriced.
Like I know like, you know,
Japan has this like weird obsession
when it comes to fruits where it's like,
oh, it's from this-
- You gotta massage it.
- No, no, no.
It's not even that.
It's like, oh, it's from
the specific prefecture
that specializes in that, therefore,
if you want to buy an apple
from like Aomori prefecture,
which is like known for their apples,
it's like a regular Apple,
like I don't know about the UK,
but at least in Australia it's like
if you want like a freshly grown-
- We don't fucking know
where it's come from.
- Good quality, like a home grown apple,
the most you'd pay is maybe like a buck.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I've never paid more
than 50 cents for an apple.
- No, no, no.
- I think I'd be shocked if I
paid more than like 30 pence.
- Where as here, if you want
a specialized branded apple
which is like the only kind of apples
they have here for some reason,
it's like, oh yeah, 600 yen, please.
- Because there's no cheap brand here.
Every brand has a certain story.
And it's like that, it's like, you know,
when you have Asian
grandparents or something,
everything they feed you has
health benefits or something.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- They feed you like this
vegetable or this fruit.
And then you're like, oh,
this is really good for X.
It says, it's not proven,
but it's like a wives tale.
Right?
- The amount of like fat
products they sell here
is like incredible.
You think that we're in
the age of science, right?
I thought that people like
knew that half the shit
they see on packaging is bullshit, right?
The amount of just weight loss things
that I've seen here is incredible.
Like put this pad on your belly
and it will just magically
go because of the gels.
And it's like that's just
not how the body works.
- You know what's kind
of incredible as well
when it comes to weight
loss culture here in Japan,
apparently I saw somewhere
and I don't know, don't quote me on this,
but I saw it a while ago that
Japan is really interesting
when it comes to weight loss
because we're one of the most-
- Healthiest country.
- Healthiest countries in the world
and yet I think it's something ridiculous,
like one in three people diet.
- It's crazy, I don't understand.
- And I'm like you don't need to diet
and that whole thing comes from the whole
ridiculous standard of
beauty here in Japan
where everybody needs to be bulimic
otherwise you're not considered beautiful.
But going back to the fruit thing,
I remember me and Arki went
to this new supermarket
that opened up near our place.
And I wanted to check
out the fruit section
because I'm always curious.
I'm like how can we
get ripped off anymore?
And there were like these packet of,
there were these cherries, right?
I love eating cherries.
- Oh God.
- There were these packet of
like cherries from America.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which are like, there
was 30 of them in there
and it was like 400 yen.
I'm like, okay, a tad
expensive, but not too bad.
Right next to there,
there was a pack of another 30 cherries,
but they were from like
Ibaraki or somewhere local.
And it was obviously some
kind of brand, right?
Guess how much these cherries were?
- Just going off Japan
experience, like 30 bucks.
- Okay. So like 3000 yen.
How much do you think it was?
- Like 2,500 yen.
- 2,500 yen, right?
- 25 bucks.
- Yeah, think of 6,500 yen.
- Oh, Jesus.
- Oh my God.
- For 30 cherries home grown.
- Okay.
- Like what?
I was really tempted to
buy it just being like
I swear to God if one cherry
doesn't give me an orgasm,
like it's not worth it.
- Yeah. I know right?
- It's just not worth it.
- It's good fruit, don't get me wrong.
But is it worth the fucking
premium that I'm paying?
- Right.
- I don't think so.
I don't think so.
- It's so stupid.
It's already a luxury just
to buy regular fruit here,
regular non-branded fruit.
- Exactly.
- It's like who is buying this?
That's my biggest concern is like
what kind of fruit elitist is
buying these like $60 cherries
from like down the road?
- Five star Michelin fucking cherries.
- It's like who is buying these?
And being like mm, yes,
I can definitely taste the
homegrown quality in this.
- It's the fucking elderly.
It's the grandma that's like,
"This is hidden health benefits."
(guys laughing)
- This is low GMO.
- This cherry will fix
your erectile dysfunction.
(guys laughing)
- This isn't from America.
It's home grown.
- Going back to people
who stay thin in Japan.
I think one preconception I had is that
I would just move to Japan
because Japanese food is so healthy,
you just like lose weight automatically.
I'd like zero effort,
lose weight automatically.
- Most restaurants have a menu.
Surprise. Surprise.
And i you just pick the unhealthy option,
you get the unhealthy option.
- Yep, you gain just as much weight.
I think the whole
preconception is that like,
I think especially when
it comes from Americans-
- Yeah.
- It's not so much about the actual fact
that like the food is healthier
and I'm sure like if you
like constantly go eat out
of like traditional Japanese restaurants
that serve traditional Japanese food,
yes, you're probably
getting healthier stuff.
But I think it just seems healthier
especially when compared to like Americans
because the portion
sizes are just smaller.
- That and like the whole konbini,
all that stuff is definitely not healthy.
- Oh no, no, no, no.
- That stuff's awful for you.
- It's delicious, but it's not healthy.
- That's the problem,
everything's delicious
so you just want to keep
eating more and more.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- I think we mistake it as
like a food culture thing
as to why everyone's so thin here
but it's definitely like
when you've live here
you realize really quickly
it's a lifestyle thing.
- Yeah. It's definitely a lifestyle thing.
- Because they walk so much,
most people do exercise unless
they're super busy with work,
and I mean, that's
already draining enough,
but I've noticed that people
don't really eat lunch
or breakfast much here.
It's like a light bite most of the time,
unless it's a business meal,
then that's when they'll eat lunch.
But most people I think
just have like an onigiri
or like a small snack.
- Oh, like a CalorieMate?
- Right.
And even then I think most
people are just too exhausted
by the time they finish work,
they just have something
just 'cause they need to
and then they go to bed.
Where, I mean, when you're a YouTuber,
I eat because I'm bored and trust me,
there's more than enough stuff to eat here
that is like terrible for you.
- I'm sure the amount of food
they're just like are
used to eating as well
is greatly different to any
standard of a Westerner, right?
- Oh no, like for me,
whenever I have like a
sweet, like an ice cream-
- Everything is sweet here.
- Yeah, everything.
- Everything.
- And it's so good.
- It's amazing.
- Normally I hate sweets,
but now when I go to a konbini
I have to get at least
one snack or one sweet.
- But like the one thing I can't forgive,
especially, this is not just Japan.
This is all Asian
countries is sweet bread.
- Oh.
I just think they-
- I don't understand it.
- I can't speak of other Asian countries,
but this country's bread is a joke.
- Oh yeah.
It's still bread.
- No.
- Half the bread that you can choose,
I have not seen a single bread
that is like multi-grain bread.
Like just brown bread, right?
Finding anything but white bread
and then sometimes like
bread with custard in it.
Who the fuck wants bread
with custard in it?
- Okay, I fuck with
bread with custard in it.
- No.
- I fuck with it because I
grew up eating that shit.
- And then there's other stuff,
and it's like in the UK,
the one thing that I realized
now I took most for granted
was just a loaf of bread.
- Yeah.
- I feel like the one thing
that everyone feels entitled to
in the UK is a loaf of bread.
It is like the staple of the house, right?
Everyone has a loaf of bread.
- You just go to like
fucking Tesco's, Waitrose.
- It's one pound at most.
You could even get the cheaper option,
still a whole loaf of bread
for like 80 cents, right?
80 cents, ADM, whatever.
- How many slices of bread
do you get in the UK?
- You get like 12, like
12, you get a full loaf.
It's like this big.
In Japan, you get half the fucking loaf
and they've cut it.
- You get six slices.
- You get six slices, but
it's not only six slices,
it's like a brick of fucking like-
- It's not even a slice.
It's too thick to make a sandwich out of.
- It's so thick that the toaster struggles
to toast it all the way through.
You have to like put that
bitch in for like 10 minutes
and it's like lightly brown.
I'm just like, I just want toast!
- Yeah, I think bread has been the thing
that I've missed the most.
If not that, cheese.
- Oh, don't get me started on cheese.
- You can get good cheese here,
but for the same block
of cheese in the UK,
like a kilogram of cheese,
I would pay like two, three pounds, right?
So that's like, what?
Four or five bucks.
Here, if I want like
200 grams or 500 grams
of good actual cheese,
not that God awful shit they have here,
it's like 15 bucks.
And I'm not paying that much for cheese
'cause I just can't like In my head.
- I mean, it's a bigger struggle for me
considering that Australia
is known for its cheese,
like all supermarkets in
Australia have an aisle
specifically for cheese, right?
- Here, you have to go to a
specific specialized supermarket
for foreign cheese and
everything like that.
- I just want to grate cheese on shit.
- Or it's in a tiny corner
of the dairy section.
- Yeah, and it's like the
most processed fucking cheese.
- It's American cheese.
- They'll have like 10000 meters of tofu.
Don't you worry about it.
They'll have every single tofu imaginable.
They'll have like, it's the same tofu
but it's like instead of
0000F on the color grade,
it's 000.1F.
- It's one shade whiter.
- It's literally like
the shit they'll sell.
But like cheese, no way.
Get that shit out of here.
We don't need cheese.
- You know it's fucked when we
have more variations of natto
than we do cheese.
(guys laughing)
I mean, not that I'm
complaining, but yeah.
- I don't know how you handle natto, man.
- I just grew up with it, man.
- I'm open to things.
- Yeah.
- I think I have a really good palate.
I can eat anything but natto,
I don't know what the fuck that is.
- I don't want to be that guy,
but it's an acquired taste.
(guys laughing)
- You can say that again.
You know, I feel that
I'm pretty international
and I'm open to try new things.
There's a few things in the
world that I just don't get.
Natto is one of them.
I'm sorry to betray my own country.
Durian is another one.
I'm sorry, guys.
- I've never tried real durian.
- I've never tried durian as well.
- But I've always wanted to.
- What are some like,
I guess while we're talking about it,
what are some misconceptions about Japan
that you think you experienced?
'Cause for me, I know, I
thought for some reason
I thought I was gonna eat way more fish
by just being, I mean, in comparison
I guess I do eat slightly more fish
but I thought fish was gonna be way more
of a factor in my life
than it actually is.
I feel like if you want
to avoid fish in Japan,
it is so easy.
- Oh yeah, very, very.
I mean, I think that also
comes from the whole fact
that because there were
more foreigners living here,
like there were just like,
especially between the four years
that I've been living here,
there are so many more vegetarian
and vegan places open now.
It's incredible, especially in Tokyo,
but like, yeah, no, I agree.
I love me my fish don't get me wrong.
- Same, same.
- But I'm definitely not
going to eat sushi every week
like most my fans think I am.
- Yeah, I can't eat sushi every day.
It's like a nice little treat.
- Right, right.
- I don't know what you guys are on about.
If I could eat sushi every week,
I would and I do most weeks.
Pre-quarantine,
going to this dollar sushi chain,
I fucking love it because
you get better sushi
than you do for paying 30 quid
or whatever you do in the UK.
- Oh yeah.
- For a fucking dollar.
And it's fucking amazing
and I do eat quite a lot fish
mostly because I eat sushi a lot
and when you cook at home,
you know cooking salmon.
- Oh yeah, I love cooking salmon, cod
like that's so good.
- Yeah, yah.
- And because there's so
much fish, like in the UK
sometimes you could get like meat
that's been like seasoned already.
And you can get like fish
and supermarkets here
that's already been
pre-seasoned, everything,
so literally all you gotta
do is open that bad boy up,
throw it in a pan and you've
got an amazing tasting fish.
It's so good.
- Yeah.
- I think it's just habit basically,
because if you don't have
the habit of eating fish,
there's so many other
shit that you could eat
because it's so readily available.
- Pizza potato, that's the best.
(guys laughing)
if you don't know what pizza potato is,
come to the Japan, it's amazing.
I fucking stand by it.
- But that's the thing right-
- Sorry, I interrupted you.
- I think most people think that like, oh,
all there is to eat is just
like sushi is because like
as obvious as this is gonna sound,
Japanese food culture is
just so much more than that.
It is so much more than fish.
- I have consistently had
the best Italian food here
as opposed to-
(Joey laughing)
- There's someone Italian
out there just cringing.
- Yeah, he's like what the fuck.
- Going to Italy, it's no contest, right?
But compared to the UK where
it was literally like again,
it was a coin toss, right?
You'd go to a place and the
pasta was like god awful.
Like it's the saddest
carbonara, which you know,
how can you fuck that up?
That's like pasta 101, right?
You come here and I feel
like you just always
consistently have a good
experience with every kind of food.
Right?
- Right.
- I mean, you know this, Chinese
food in the UK is a joke.
- We're not gonna get into that.
(guys laughing)
I could spend a lot
talking about Chinese food-
- Any kind of cuisine you can imagine,
except maybe like American
food like portion heavy-
- Like diner food.
- Yeah meat, like really ribs and stuff.
Yeah, it's hard to get that,
but I'm fine with going to
America or going back to the UK
and having that myself every now and then
for the overall trade-off of all right,
consistently I get better meals, right?
- Right, right, right.
- Is there anything else that
haven't met your expectations
or haven't met your preconceptions?
- I want to know as like
a non-resident, right?
Or like non-Japanese.
- This is gonna sound
dumb as fuck, all right?
And I know it's going to sound dumb,
but I knew things were
going to be difficult
that I couldn't speak
Japanese or read Japanese.
More so read than anything.
I feel like for some
reason you can be fine
not speaking Japanese
here, but if you can't read
like you're in for a storm of trouble
because there are so many things,
and I think we all can agree on this.
If Amazon didn't exist here and-
- Oh my God.
- If Amazon didn't have
English settings here,
I genuinely don't know what I would do
because the websites here in Japanese,
like I don't know if
they've done this on purpose
or due to the old interface,
they do not work well
with Google Translate.
- I mean, it's all going
back to that 90s web-
- No, they don't know how
to design their websites.
It's not user-friendly.
So if you can't speak
Japanese or read Japanese
you're kind of fucked.
- Yeah, yeah.
And Google Translate does not help.
- No, it doesn't help.
It can help you kind of
feel your way through
but you cannot tell what
the fuck you're doing.
The only reason we've been
able to get through it
is because we've had a fucking-
- Got friends, we got
a company helping us.
It makes it so much easier.
Oh yeah, Joey, shout out to Joey.
- I am that friend.
- Yeah.
- Joey helped me a lot when we moved here,
like helped me out doing all the dumb-
- I had to go to the town hall with you
to fill our your papers.
- That's the thing, right?
It's like you think like
in the big population areas
they'd have like a lot of English support,
but I think they said if you
come on these certain days,
like setting up internet,
do you remember how much
of a hassle that was?
- Oh my god.
- I remember the AU, right?
They say they have an
English location in Shinjuku.
- Oh yeah.
- That's a fucking lie.
- No, no, their English location
is that they have a tablet
which can call a call center
that can translate the
person for you kind of,
but not really but that's the closest-
- But did you even get that far?
'Cause I didn't even get
to the guy on the tablet.
I just turned up saying on the website,
this says this is the English location.
And they were like, no.
And I'm like, well, what do I do?
How the fuck do I get internet now?
Help me!
- Luckily I had a cousin
who worked in Japan
so she could speak Japanese.
She helped me through so much
and I don't know what
I would do without her.
And same with you.
- Yeah, same, same.
I need a lot of help.
- You feel like a baby.
- I genuinely don't know how,
there are some foreigners here
who can't even speak English
who somehow made it here on their own.
And I'm like, how the
fuck did you do that?
- Because at least they have
a lot of English words, right?
And a lot of English options sometimes
but if can't speak English,
fuck, I don't know what you-
- I don't know how they do it.
- I don't know, like English
is hard enough as it is.
If you can't speak Japanese
then I think you're pretty much fucked.
(guys laughing)
- Real positive message
coming out of this episode.
- No, no, no, because that's the thing,
a lot of people don't talk about
which is how hard it is to live here,
actually live here
without speaking Japanese
because coming on, like
we said, it's so different
living here as working here
and just live visiting here as a tourist.
There's a world of difference.
And there's so many little
things like for example,
registering with the town hall.
How the fuck am I supposed to do that
if I don't speak Japanese?
'Cause they don't speak English.
And all the forms were in Japanese.
- Yeah, the forms, they tell
you that you need to do that
within two weeks of moving
here are also in Japanese.
- It's simple, just learn Japanese
in the two weeks that you're here.
- The only reason we knew is
because the lawyers told us,
"Hey, you've got do this."
But if we didn't know
that, I don't know what,
I would have just carried on living-
- You need a dedicated
agency just to help you
with all the admin stuff-
- I mean, I can understand the language
and I still have to learn
from my cousins who live here,
like this is just how it works.
- Yeah.
- Like oh shit, I have
to go to the town hall
and register for my address
and my health certificate
and all of that shit.
I never had to experience
that living in Australia.
I never had to experience that
while visiting here, right?
So it's just, it's overwhelming.
And like it's like massive kudos
to people who don't know Japanese
or even don't know English.
gain, I don't know how the fuck they do it
without the help of an agency.
- To clarify, you can live here
if you don't speak any Japanese
or for if you're learning.
But I think if you're
somehow coming here alone
without anyone helping you,
it's gonna be hell on earth.
'Cause it was hell enough
with multiple ways of
us having help, right?
And I felt so bad for Joey,
the amount of times I
have to ask him for help.
I was like, he fucking
hates me at this point.
- It's okay.
- Every day I'm coming over with a form.
- I still like you, don't worry.
(guys laughing)
- Like hey Joey, what does this say?
And then also until you
figure this out, right?
If you miss a package in the post,
you get a little form through your mailbox
that's all in Japanese
and you need to figure out
how the fuck you're gonna
reschedule this thing.
Luckily, I found a way eventually
which was scan the barcode
with whatever thing you have,
it'll take you to a website,
use Google translate to translate it
and then hope that the
translation are rough enough
where you can like figure
out what's being said
and that's what I do every time now.
But for the first week
where I didn't know that,
every time I missed a package,
I was like, "Hey Joey,
can you call them up
and tell them I'm gonna be home by 12?"
- There was like a month where
I was calling up these guys
more often for his packages
than it was for my own packages.
- I felt so bad, but I was
like I need the package.
It's my fucking desk.
And again, okay, let's
trace it back again.
And I hate being like nice
to a trillion dollar company
like Amazon, but without
them and the English,
'cause you can just change
it to English, right?
And they also they have
support in English.
I'd know, 'cause I've had to
like return items and stuff.
It's literally no different
from using Amazon in the UK.
Except maybe sometimes the translations
don't work one for one,
but you can pretty much
find what you want.
You can type it in in
English and it comes up.
- We basically furnished our entire-
- Yeah, my whole house is Amazon.
- Using Amazon.
- Yeah.
- Because they have like a Japanese Ikea
which is called Nitori,
but you have to go to the store,
you have to register, you
have to put in your address
and all that stuff.
- And it takes like 20
days to deliver anything.
Did you know that?
How crazy is that?
If you want like their version of like,
there's Ikea here as well,
but it's very expensive.
If you buy stuff from Nitori,
which is like their version
of Ikea like you said,
it's like, there's a lot,
there's a lot of waiting time,
like 20 days I think for some products.
- Yeah.
- Geeze.
- And I was like I can't
wait 20 days for a bed.
I want to sleep.
Like what do you mean?
- Let me just sleep on the
hard floor for 30 days.
- Yeah, what am I gonna do?
And yeah, just also any advice
to someone moving to Japan,
please make sure your house
has AC before you move in,
because I didn't and I had to
pay I think it was like 2005-
- Your previous tenant jacked the AC.
- He gutted, he fucking
gutted the whole place.
He took everything.
He took the light bulbs.
Who takes light bulbs?
- Oh yeah, that's a frequent
occurrence you'll see,
like going into a new apartment,
there won't be any lights.
You'll have to buy your own lights.
- When I move out of a place,
I'll leave stuff that I
think is like super generic
that you don't need to think about.
I'll leave the bulbs in.
If I have like a doormat,
I'll just leave the doormat.
Like whatever, they can throw
it away if they don't want it.
But like they took everything.
They took everything.
- They took everything from me!
- So I moved in with no AC
and it was getting really cold.
And I think there's one cosplay video
where I was fucking
freezing during this video
and I was getting like naked for it.
And I was like (shivers).
- Not only that,
but you were in like the
coldest rooms in the house.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
The tatami room.
- The tatami room, which retains no heat.
- So just like before you move,
please, before you move into an apartment
please make sure there's AC there
otherwise that's gonna be
a huge cost when you move.
So I had to pay 2000 plus
dollars for two AC units.
- Jesus.
- And I don't know what
I'm gonna do with that
if I ever move back to the UK.
- Jack it, dude, jack it.
- I guess I have to sell it.
- Bring it with you, UK could use AC.
- But okay, let's say you
pay for an apartment, right?
You paid for the AC in
that apartment, right?
Like that's part of your bill.
Whereas I had to pay 2000 independently
so that you could argue
that my rent has gone up.
- Yeah.
- It's just like dumb shit like that
that I didn't consider.
- No. So, okay.
One thing that was different for me
is how much I thought I
would go to Akihabara.
(guys laughing)
Versus how much I
actually go to Akihabara.
- Onsens too.
- Yeah. Yeah. Because every time we-
- We haven't gone since you guys moved.
- I know, I know.
- I know, I know!
- It makes me so sad.
- 'Cause I remember like
every time we visited here
on holiday, we'd spend half our time there
or something like that.
- Akihabara, yeah.
- Oh, of course.
- Going to Akihabara is
the proper weeb experience.
- I'm not proud should
admit that but it was like,
imagine every single anime
convention shoved into one.
- It is like the mecca of the weebs.
It is just the holy land for weebs.
- But then you move here
and you're like, man,
Akihabara is not only a long way away,
but you can get a lot of shit
better online for cheaper
if you can figure out
Japanese websites, right?
- Not only that, but there are cities that
are better for all round experiences.
That's why I love like Ikebukuro.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Because with Akihabara, you
only go there for anime.
And if you want to do something else,
then it's not the best place to go.
But if you go to somewhere like Ikebukuro,
you can still shop for anime figurines.
You can still go down-
- Go down Otome Road.
- Exactly, exactly.
Go go to the Animate there,
which is also in Akihabara.
But then you could also
go to Izakaya afterwards
or go karaoke or you know?
A lot of other things,
it's a lot more varied.
There's a lot more variation
outside of Akihabara
then if you want just-
- Not to downplay Akihabara though.
- No.
- It's amazing.
It's great.
- Every weeb should go to Akihabara.
(Joey laughing)
- It's an experience.
- You'll have a spiritual awakening
when you go to Akihabara.
- It is crazy like the
first time you go there.
It's like holy shit, what?
- This is what I dreamed about.
- Three Sega Arcades right
next to each other, why?
- It's just kind of like
information overload, right?
You get blasted with so many lights
with so much shit just around you,
you don't know where to go.
You can spend an entire fucking
day in one store easily.
- Oh yeah.
'Cause if you want to
look for deals, right?
And figures, you got to
pull out the whole shelf
'cause they hide shit
like way in the back.
And sometimes you might find that one deal
that is like all you fucking talk about.
When I found that one thing
for like 20 bucks, yeah.
- I want to get a figurine
for like the best price
you got to create a Google Spreadsheet.
- [Garnt] Exactly.
- All right, this still
has it for this price
but the store down there
has it for 10% cheaper.
So you just gotta like
keep track of everything.
- And then you ultimately realize
that it's cheaper on Yahoo Auctions.
- It's like half price on Amazon.
- It's way better to buy online.
- Yeah, even Amazon here,
the figures are way cheaper
sometimes than the stores,
which is like weird.
- See, because for me like Amazon itself
was just like a huge revelation
because we don't have Amazon in Australia.
- Wow.
- Oh, you don't?
- No, we don't.
- That's so weird to think
there's a world without Amazon.
- How does a country
function without Amazon?
- We have eBay.
And we have like our own
version of Amazon called Gumtree
which is just-
- Oh, we have Gumtree.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Gumtree is where I used
to sell sketchy stuff
to sketchy people.
- That's like the
Craigslist of Amazon though.
- Yeah, pretty much.
But like Gumtree, I'm pretty
sure was an Australian company.
And so we have Gumtree
and eBay and that's it.
We don't have Amazon.
So back when I was living in Australia
and talking to American YouTuber friends
who were like, "Oh yeah, I
just got that off Amazon."
I'm just like, yeah, about that.
I, uh, they're seeling it for
three times the price on eBay.
Does that count?
(guys laughing)
I hated it.
So when I moved here,
Amazon was just like-
- Whoa.
- Holy shit.
It's gonna arrive tomorrow?
- Next day delivery?
- Fucking hell, yeah, so that was amazing.
- Because the thing about Akihabara
I feel it's more of an
experience than the actual,
you don't go there to actually shop,
you go there for like
the Akihabara experience.
'Cause like I remember
one of the biggest things
that I noticed going to Akihabara is that
you can walk into one shop
and you think it's like
this single store shop
and you're just gonna
come in and come out.
And then it turns out to
be seven fucking stories.
- Of shops.
- Yeah, of shops.
And then you waste five hours there
'cause there's so much
stuff in this one shop.
- It's so tightly packed in.
- Yeah.
- Buy used figures as well.
Their version of used here is a joke.
It's immaculate, it's immaculate.
- Like I feel bad now
because when I use something,
it's fucking messy as fuck.
I have books that have
like one single folded page
or something that I like
placed it down wrong.
And that's just unusable here.
- Yeah. They'll be like
damaged goods, looks very used.
And I'm like what the fuck?
Used in the UK is like if
it's just barely functioning.
- Yeah, barely functioning,
probably has like an STD.
I don't fucking know
what it's been through.
- Whereas here it's like
have you opened the box?
Yeah, it's used.
- Which is fucking amazing how Connor,
you found probably the
only used product in Japan,
which was your fridge.
- Oh, God.
- Can we talk about that?
- Yeah.
- I'll let you tell the story,
but it definitely was
not in immaculate shape.
- So we had spent A lot
of money on moving, right?
As anyone knows moving is very expensive
and I'd heard of these like Sayonara Sales
as they're called.
People who move from Japan,
they basically sell all that stuff-
- Is that what they're called?
- Yeah, Sayonara Sale.
And so they sell all
their stuff on Craigslist
and Meilyne, kept
telling me at BookWalker,
kept telling me like,
"Dude, just buy all your
stuff on Craigslist.
It's like dirt cheap."
And I thought, wow-
- Great idea, Meilyne.
- Wow, call her out on this.
- And you know, I thought, all right,
well, Japanese people are really great
with like keeping their stuff immaculate.
So I order, I speak to
someone on Craigslist,
a sauna fridge and a laundry machine,
is that what you call it?
- A washing machine.
- I don't fucking know.
(guys laughing)
- A laundry machine.
- A laundry device machine.
Anyway, I bought it for like,
it was like 50 bucks, right?
For a fridge and a laundry-
- That's already a red flag.
- Right, right.
But there were some people who were giving
their stuff away for free.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, 'cause they
we're gonna get charged
by the local council.
- To get rid of the stuff.
- So I didn't pay for anything else,
not the moving fee or anything.
So you were there when
my houseman turned up
like a guy from New Zealand.
- Yeah, he was a Kiwi, yeah.
- Yeah, he just turned up and he was like,
"All right, I'll fucking
install the machine.
- Is that your Kiwi accent?
- Yeah, fuck it.
He's just like "I'll
fucking install it for you."
And so he was like I'll install it for you
and I think I discussed with
the person on Craigslist.
They were going charge me
like 10er for installing it.
So the guy was like,
"Oh no, fuck it, mate."
And so he installed it
and then I got like,
do you remember?
I got like angry fucking texts
off the person off Craigslist.
They were like bombarding my phone.
I picked up the phone
and then there was like an
Indian woman shouting at me.
Being like, "Why didn't
you pay him the 1000 yen?"
And I was like, "What the fuck? Shut up."
(guys laughing)
- 'Cause he said it was cool.
- I'm like, "He said it was fine,
why are you fucking spamming my phone?"
Yeah and so I was like,
I just hung up the phone.
I was like, yeah, no, he left now.
What the fuck you want me to do?
What am I supposed to do?
Stop shouting at me.
And I told her, I messaged her.
If you send me one more
message shouting at me,
I'm blocking you.
(guys laughing)
- Giving it a hard block.
- Yeah I was like, "I'm gonna block you,
don't you fucking dare talk..."
- Don't at me.
- Yeah.
- And the guy, the Kiwi called me up
and he's like, "All
right, mate, listen here.
She wants the money.
I'm gonna come back and get it."
And then I was like, "All right, fine.
I'll just give you the 10er, I don't care.
Can you just all stop calling me?"
I just enjoy my evening.
- Yeah.
- So I met him at the konbini,
gave him the 10er and then went back.
Next day I opened my fridge,
there's like five
cockroaches in my fridge.
I was like, holy fuck, right?
No wonder they didn't want
a foreigner in their house.
Imagine being the only
foreigner in your building
and that guy has cockroaches.
- The cleanest country
in the fucking world.
I swear to God.
- I'm the asshole who brought
cockroaches into this place.
So I bought a cockroach fridge.
I fucking tore this fridge apart, right?
I literally tore, you know the felt
that you have on fridges?
- Yeah.
- I tore all that shit off.
I took everything out.
I bleached the fuck out of this thing.
My house must've smelled
like a murder scene being cleaned, right?
I bleached the hell out of this thing.
And it was the most vile thing.
You know the felt thing, right?
I was shaking it out
and maybe like 100
cockroaches must've fell out.
- Ugh!
- I don't even want to know
the living conditions of the person
who sold me this fridge.
But fuck you if you ever watch this.
You are horrible.
Do not sell people your fridges
if they are in that condition.
- Exposed!
- How can you get cockroaches
in the most cleanest country
that I've ever been to?
You go on the streets here
and you don't see any fucking rubbish.
- There are less cockroaches
in the back of like a fucking Denny's here
then there were in fridge.
- Yeah.
- So that was my first
experience buying used in Japan.
(guys laughing)
Yeah and it was awful
because I just thought
like God damn it.
Like I just got this house
and I've cockroaches now.
And so I had to like
scour my whole apartment
just making sure these
cockroaches didn't go anywhere.
And two months after I
kept finding one or two
and I'm like How?
I bleached everything.
There is no reason these
things should be existing.
- That's cockroaches 101, man,
once you thought you got rid of 'em all,
they're still around.
- So now I got rid of the fridge
'cause I just thought enough is enough.
This thing looks disgusting.
I threw it out.
- It wasn't a nice looking fridge anyways.
- It was gross.
It looked like something like
a homeless man would sleep in.
- Your apartment probably
has a cockroach infection
that you just put into there.
- No, no, no, no.
I got 'em all.
- It's somewhere in the building.
I got all those fuckers, I'm just saying.
I spent a lot of time.
- That's what you think.
(guys laughing)
- But before we end this episode,
I'd like to know especially from you,
'cause I know I experienced this.
When you announced that
you moved to Japan,
'cause I kept mine
secret for like a month.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, same here.
- I didn't tell anyone about the process,
I only really told close friends but-
- Just kind of dropped it down like.
- I just kind of like made a tweet
being like I live in Japan now.
What's up?
- Everyone was like what!
- What reaction did you
experience when you tweeted that?
- I mean, everyone just assumes that,
I was following that weeb dream
that we talked about earlier
where I'm just like,
oh, you're finally being
the final form of every weeb.
You're finally in Japan.
You're gonna watch so much anime.
(guys laughing)
- You're basically Japanese now.
- I'm basically Japanese.
- Konichiwa.
- And everyone assumes I
could already speak Japanese
because I've been to Japan.
- Yeah, same.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, no, no, no, no.
I think a lot of people
just rightfully just,
okay, not rightfully, I don't know.
I would never assume if
someone moves to a country
that they can automatically
speak the language.
But I got so many comments
of people being like,
"But you can't speak Japanese,
so why would you move there?"
And I'm like I don't read.
It's not really that much of an issue.
I'm gonna learn it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but It did become an issue
and it is an issue if we
didn't have someone to help us.
- It is an issue but if you have agency
or friend's helping you-
- It's not a requirement.
- If you have Amazon.
Jeff Bezos, shout out.
Thank you.
But yeah, I mean carry on,
is that all you got?
Like everyone just assumed
the weeb dream, etc?
- Yeah, I mean, I didn't get
too much of like a reaction
apart from just everyone was happy for me,
everyone wanted to know how I moved here
or what I went through-
- Now you know.
- Yeah, exactly, now you know.
Much of the advice I can
offer isn't too helpful
because we were kind of
the first of our kind.
We were like some of the first YouTubers
to be able to move here
for being an anituber.
Basically we got so good at being a weeb
the Japanese government allowed
us to continue being weebs
and we're being paid.
They gave us a visa for
being a super fucking weeb.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- We're the anomaly.
We're the exception.
- I mean, Arki technically was-
- Yeah, no she was the first.
I'm saying like we're one of the first.
- No, of course, of course.
- 'Cause Arki was the first.
- Yeah, of course. Of course.
Yeah, no, it's kind of incredible how,
I mean, I felt the same way with RQ,
but with you guys as well
that like, wow, like anitube
has gotten to that point now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause even like three years ago
it was fucking unheard of.
- Yeah.
- Right, it's like oh
yeah, you talk about anime
on the internet for a living.
Yeah, good luck staying in your country
for the rest of your life, right?
But like now it's just an
actual viable career option.
- If you can give back
more than you take out,
then there's no reason why
I guess a government agency would not want
to have that job there
if you're giving more money
and you're not doing any harm
and you're respectful like
why wouldn't they want you?
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's been really humbling
to actually be working here
officially doing anime YouTube.
And it's been really weird.
Especially talking to people
who work in the companies,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Like directly.
- Yeah, how'd you feel your
careers have been affected
after moving here?
- I mean, I think mine's
increased dramatically
because now I do have access directly
to a lot of these productions.
I knew like a lot of people in
the industry, quote unquote,
while I was living in Australia-
- The anime industry.
But like it is a
completely different story
when you move here.
- Oh no, exactly.
- Because like most of
these Japanese companies
don't know what the fuck an email is.
- No, no.
- And they require you to meet in person.
- Yeah, want you to meet in person.
- Yeah, if you're gonna
do business in Japan
you need to have a face-to-face meeting,
no email, no fucking Zoom call.
- Not even a phone call.
It's like you need to come to our office
and we need to make sure
that you're a real person.
- Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
So it's all very traditional here.
So to do business with any anime company
which is why things move so slowly is that
you have to follow the tradition.
You have to do that face to face meeting.
They call a meeting
for any fucking reason.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Somebody sneezed in the office.
We need to discuss
whether this is a potential
anthrax infection.
- Get HR on the phone.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, career wise, I
guess for me the biggest thing
is that I just want to
experience something else
and also maybe learn another language.
Although it's painfully
difficult to learn Japanese.
- [Garnt] It is.
- I just think getting more
life skills can only be a plus,
right?
- Of course.
- If I continue doing what
I was doing in the UK,
I was doing a lot of voiceover which sure,
I could probably go and maybe go into that
when for some reason I stop doing YouTube,
but I think I just want to
learn more skills in my life
while I'm still young as well, right?
And while I'm still open to doing things
and putting myself out there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I think if anything from my career
definitely that benefit
of hopefully learning more
and making new connections with,
maybe not the industry.
I don't know what I'll go into,
but I mean, we've definitely
made connections as well
just from being in a company under-
- yeah, not even the anime industry,
just like lots of industries.
- You meet people that you
never knew that you would.
- A lot of creatives, right?
A lot of cool people.
- But like I think the biggest barrier
is the language barrier.
- Yeah.
Japanese really need to
fix their difficulty curve
because you go from fucking
playing Animal Crossing-
- To Doom Eternal Nightmare.
(guys laughing)
- Like Katakana and Hiragana
is like you're play just
playing Animal Crossing.
And then suddenly you're
doing like a no hit run
in Dark Souls or something
when Kanji gets in.
And you're like, what
the fuck is going on?
This is not the difficulty curve I wanted.
- And the problem is with Kanji at least,
not problem, I mean,
it's a really beautiful
system of writing and
I've come to appreciate it
more and more, but it's like,
if you don't understand a baseline amount,
you just can't read anything
because the moment you do,
you're like what's that?
- Welcome to the past 25 years of my life.
- And it's not like if
I was learning French
where I can sound it out and maybe like,
I just can't like, I'm like
what the fuck is that thing?
And then you're like, oh,
I know what this Kanji is.
Turns out the Kanji has five
different pronunciations
and meanings and you don't
know which one's which
'cause you just got here.
- You just have to know that shit.
- This is bullshit.
- I think that's what's
the most difficult, right?
Is that like Japan is like an
anti-phonetic country, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you can't spell shit out.
You just have to know it.
And that's why it's so
difficult for a lot of people.
I mean, like-
- We know a lot of people
who can speak Japanese
but I have not even attempted
to learn to read Japanese.
- No, no.
- It is a completely different ball game.
- Oh, it's crazy.
- Even like me having learnt it,
pretty much my first language,
I still struggle with
it every now and then.
It is like a constant
learning process for me.
And like thank God that
my mom did whip my ass
to learn it when I was
little, because Jesus Christ,
my life has been a million times easier
that I can read it and understand it.
- It's the one time when she said,
"You'll appreciate it when you're older."
And you did actually appreciate
it when you were older.
- I was like thanks, mom.
You helped build my career essentially.
- Everyone said that with Welsh.
(guys laughing)
Didn't quite pan out.
I mean, I appreciate the culture
but that's about as far
as the usefulness goes.
- But here's the question
I want to ask you guys,
well, now that you've
experienced living here for what?
Essentially seven, eight months now,
how long do you intend to stay here?
- Mhm, that's a good question.
I think I've lived here
long enough to know
that I don't want to live here forever.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- I think there's just at least right now
in how Japan is a lot of stuff
that I just like don't gel with.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think I can definitely
see myself 'cause I've-
- But a long time though.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Because I've lived there for eight months.
It's felt like I've
lived here for a month.
I haven't even reached
close to my final form.
(guys laughing)
- Is that an anime reference?
- I know we've hardly talked
about anime on this podcast,
but yeah, I mean, I feel like
I want to explore Japan more.
I want to learn the language
way more proficiently
than I have now.
I want to take advantage of it way more
and I want to experience
Japanese cultures more.
- [Connor] Yeah, same.
- Because the one target
I've set myself I should say
is being able to have a conversation
with some of the businesses
and go into some of the office parties
and actually being able to participate
in the conversation and
everything like that.
That's my goal when it
comes to learning, you know?
- Yeah. Same.
I just wanna be able to communicate
and learn a bit of Kanji, right?
Learn the basics just
so I can like figure out
what the McDonald's menu
says, you know what I mean?
Like yeah,
I can definitely see it being
like a second home to me.
Like a place where maybe
I can easily go back
to it months periods.
But I think like when
I'm like 50 or whatever,
I think I'm gonna miss the how,
because I think I've been really ingrained
in British culture of like
how friendly and open it is.
I really like that, especially in Wales,
you just rock up to a pub and
you can speak to anyone there
in the small pubs in Wales.
I love that.
And I kind of miss that a bit.
And I think, yeah, I don't know.
I mean I'm eight months in,
maybe in a podcast in a year
we'll talk about it and our
minds will have changed.
I'll be like I want to
live here forever, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think 'cause right now I
feel like a foreigner still.
Right?
And I think that's
probably never gonna change
but maybe at some point I'll finally feel
like I can call this place home.
- Yeah, yeah.
It might smoothen out a little bit more.
- Probably, I imagine it will.
Unless I get arrested
and convicted of a crime
that I was accused of and
I'm in prison for 100 years,
but what are the odds of that?
- Before we end the podcast,
there was one story I wanted to end on,
which is like it completely
shattered what my preconceptions
of moving to Japan would be.
And that was one of the company
parties that we attended
with a look BookWalker and GeeXPlus
and Kadokawa in general
and it was to do with my fiance, Sydney.
So what happened was we
went to a company party,
everyone got pretty merry.
And then we went a bar afterwards, right?
- Oh, I think I know
what you're gonna say.
- Yeah.
(guys laughing)
And so it was like a very intimate bar.
So it didn't fit a lot of people.
- Room for like 10 people maybe.
- Yeah, yeah, a good 10 people.
And there were a lot of
people from the company,
some pretty high up from the company
and then we started
singing karaoke together.
And so Sydney being the drunken
little weeaboo that she is.
- She's such a weeaboo.
- Unlike us, unlike us
she went through her weeb phase, right?
She went proper full cringey
weeb phase, unlike us.
- Sydney, I love you if you watch this.
Isn't she like kind of the face
of the cringey weeb person on a video?
- According to the internet, yeah.
- Sydney is gonna fucking
kill me for saying that.
- She had that phase where she went there.
So we started singing karaoke
and she starts singing
the Anohana end, right?
- And me and Garnt were
like fuck, why, why?
- What the fuck are you doing?
You're in front of a lot of
important people in the company.
And she starts bailing
the fucking Anohana ending
and then the fucking
businessmen start clapping
and cheering her on and
started singing along.
And I'm just sitting there like-
- We were both shocked, I remember.
- I couldn't believe what I was seeing.
I looked at Connor and I'm like,
"Is this r/really happened right now?
Are we living a 2007 Tumblr post?"
Like oh yeah, yeah.
So like I moved to Japan and yeah,
I was in a important business
meeting, a business party.
And then we started singing
the Anohana opening,
ending even.
And then everyone started clapping
and cheering and it was amazing.
I'm like this is so surreal right now.
- It's literally an r/that
happened post, right?
It's like this definitely happened.
- Oh my god.
- But it's great
'cause I feel like when you
do sing stuff like that,
they never like, "Oh my God
they're trying to be like us."
They're like "Oh my God,
they care about our culture.
That's so cool."
- Yeah, they really do.
And I guess that's what I want to end on
which is like I think it's,
we started on the good sides
and the bad sides of Japan
but I think they really
do care about our culture.
They really care about learning more
and they are open to foreigners.
There's just sometimes a lot of barriers
that come between that.
And I guess one of the
biggest things you can do
is learn Japanese because that's such a-
- They love it.
They love it if you speak Japanese.
- Yeah.
- To them, it's like,
you've made an effort
to learn their culture.
- No, I mean, and likewise, right?
If somebody comes over to your country
and they can understand your language
like that immediately, like, oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, dude, if you
could speak Welsh in Wales,
like you're immediately like loved,
'cause people in Welsh can't even Wales.
Welsh people can't even
speak Welsh, right?
I can imagine it's like
one of those, right?
And I think like you said, right?
All differences aside and
all complaints that we have,
like at the end of the day,
I don't think I've ever
spoken to a person here
who's been rude to me and
everyone has super nice
and you might get stared at or anything
but that's not a place of
aggression or anything.
They just don't see it often.
And at the end of the day,
they're really, really nice people.
- No, the positives definitely
outweigh the negatives.
- Oh 100%.
I mean, I'm just British, right?
So to me, it's like 1%
negative, 99% positive.
I only see this, right?
That's what your raised as British.
- Exactly.
- But overall, it's an amazing country
and I'm glad that we had
the chance to move here.
- I'm having a great fucking time.
- Oh, yeah.
- I'm glad you guys
are having a fun time.
- With the boys.
- With the boys!
- Get to do this fucking podcast.
- TTP!
(guys laughing)
Oh my God.
- It was a good two episode run then, ay?
- Yeah.
(guys laughing)
Thanks for tuning into the final episode.
- So I think that's a
good place to end it.
So thank you very much for tuning in
to Trash Taste Podcast Episode Two.
We didn't have any Twitter questions yet
because episode one hasn't
aired as of recording this.
- But make sure to go follow
@TrashTastePod on Twitter.
Give us your suggestions.
- Go to the subreddit.
- Oh yeah, we have a subreddit as well.
You've made it so.
- We have a subreddit, r/TrashTaste.
My username is ICameForMemes,
don't ask me why.
(guys laughing)
It's a throw away account,
I had to make something.
- So if you don't want to use Twitter,
you can always hit us up on a subreddit,
give us topic suggestions, questions,
any of that kind of stuff.
- Yeah, where you get to get
more community involvement.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Yeah, exactly.
We can't wait for all this there.
- 'Cause right now it's just us
just fucking talking to each other.
We don't know what's gonna happen.
- This is just another
fucking Friday Night.
(guys laughing)
So yeah, we'll see you in episode three.
- Thank you for being
such a good host, Garnt.
- Thank you very much.
Happy birthday to me.
(Joey speaking Japanese)
- [Joey] Woo!
(chill music)